again if p whoever is using their
computers as well always make sure that
you also have your speakers and your
microphone
the time being 9 30 i call this meeting
of the public works and highways
committee to order
as chair of the
house public works and highways
committee i find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of covert 19 pandemic in
accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order
2020.04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing on house bill
with a full committee work session to
follow
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public serve
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting
you through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting via the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting
complies with house rules and with rsa
91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call 271
or email
hcs
leg.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled i want to
introduce the staff that are on the
meeting assisting us
brad
greenland committee researcher and
christopher shea of the lba
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
let us start the meeting by taking a
roll call attendance
when each member states their present
please also state whether it's
with you during this meeting which is
required under the right to know law
this court if you would call the rule
thank you mr chair
representative graham
president in the community room
mcconkey
representative mills is here in the
committee room
representative samara
i'm here in my office conference room
can you hear me
yes yes sir we can't representative
philadelphia
representative
here am i in hillsborough my house
thank you
representative newton
yes i'm here i'm in rochester at my
house and my wife is in the house
somewhere
representative boards
representative kolansky
because
kaczynski's here
thank you representative representative
kolansky
representative thompson
representative clutier president in the
committee room
thank you representative
edgar president at home my wife kathy's
in the house
thank you
representative evil
home alone in new london
thank you representative jack here in
thank you representative faulkner
i'm here in swansea at home my wife is
in the other room
thank you sir representative newman
yes here in nashua my husband is in the
house
i'm present
this is representative grassy who's
replacing representative eaton
representative peterson
present uh at home in manchester alone
thank you representative bonker
present at home in exeter my wife dawn
is elsewhere in the house
thank you
i will now open the hearing on house
bill 25
and act making appropriations for
capital improvements
and i'll ask the prime sponsor to
introduce the bill and ask the court to
take the gamble because i have the black
sponsor
thank you
uh mr chairman members of the committee
for the record i am representative john
a graham hillsboro district seven which
is the town of bedford
i would like to introduce um house bill
25a and act making appropriations for
capital improvements
what we have in front of us is what the
governor proposed
um
we will be hearing testimony from
various people
in support or opposition and that it
will be our job to make sure that the
needs of the state
are met as we go forward with making
any deletions additions or changes to
what the governor has proposed
i will not take any questions at this
time we can make discussions during
our uh
work sessions and executive sessions on
the bill
um
and with that mr chairman
i will take the gamble back
you will
thank you
um
it has been a long-standing practice
within the public works
and highways committee that the chairman
is the prime sponsor of house bill 25
every biennium
but he also then becomes a member of the
committee able to
uh participate in questioning anybody
who wants to
testify or the rest
it is because all
i have done with this particular piece
of legislation
is bring forward what the governor has
asked us to look at
i will say who's here and wants to speak
um
representative oregon had asked to speak
but i do not see him on here
um
representative greg
all right
and yes
good
good morning
and russia
is testifying an opposition to
the bill that is currently before us
before you start if i can make one
comment uh representative for those of
you who are
attending this virtually from members of
the public
if you wish to
testify
please electronically raise your hand
it would be helpful for those of us who
are trying to manage who is going to
speak or not speak
thank you
yes thank you i'm i'm jackie grota i am
a state representative representing
district 24 the towns of rye and
newcastle
um first i would like to clarify i don't
i'm not opposed to the bill
um
i didn't know quite how to state my
position
because i would look like right now the
um
the the coastal flooding model as
proposed by des is not in the bill
and i'm my testimony um
well i sent a letter
to you i hope that you received it
which uh clarified the importance of
that model to the seacoast
and i just want to stress that
because this is a dynamic model
how restrictions like bridges and canals
and sg not estuaries would affect
the
flooding on the seacoast during a
a weather situation
i think it's important to know that
the seacoast would not be affected
uniformly
but some areas of the seacoast would be
affected
at a greater
significance
so it allows us to look at the seacoast
as a whole rather than a piecemeal
effort which would also help
if we needed to
design when we need to design roads and
um
and it could it's it
allows for us to do that and maintain
a sustainable
natural resource that is not only a home
for our residents
and
their livelihood is also an important
tourist destination for the for the
state
and i just i'm here to see if you have
any questions
i don't really
feel i need to spend a lot of time
with you
unless you have questions for me i don't
want to
i know how how long these hearings can
last
uh thank you representative
just one comment i was unable and i
think several of the other members were
unable to open
uh the attachment that you sent with
your uh written testimony and i tried
several different uh
platforms on apps and could not get it
open
i will reset i will resend it
thank you
are there any questions from members of
seeing none thank you
all right tell you what we're going to
do
tell you what we're going to do here for
a minute
um
i have no other hands raised the only
other person who indicated that they
wanted to
testify
um
it's not on
yeah she doesn't just want to know
um
so
we will wait about five minutes just
because this is a zoom platform people
may be having a moment to hook up
um i would hate to cut anybody off by
closing the public hearing so quickly
at this hearing
but
if not
it is i have
i will give it seven minutes for other
people to come on
and then see if there's not i will close
the volunteering and we'll go into our
work session
thank you
all so we're not in recess
yeah
we're just
well deserved
well-deserved
than this at least in past years
people i fully expected
a couple of people with some emails yeah
the agencies
they're all still playing show up right
here
the commute wasn't too bad this morning
i've never taken so long cement trucks
in my life
all right
picture
that's so prefer to be here to meet but
it is so difficult to see that screening
that's right that's yeah that's why
you know everybody wants to see
additional stuff
so who's got the car now no until up
front i went to sullivan tire when
they uh
got it right in
20 minutes all you got to do is get the
marty is it possible to go to uh speaker
i just i can't
i can't see where we are thank you so
much
appreciate you doing it
seems like since there's only this many
people who show up that could move that
i
always liked when they'd asked me like i
is
uh
so
uh thank you mr chairman uh just to let
you know that there is an individual
that's that's trying to get on now
and uh i just thought i would let you
know that so i know it's getting very
close to the to the time period that you
would mention the closing
that's seven
all right i'd like to call the meeting
back
um
order
again i would remind everybody who is
attending for members of the public
if you wish to speak
please raise your
virtual hand
so indicate
right now i have nobody
here
waiting to testify or have their hand
raised to testify on house bill 25
however
representative anchor just mentioned
that he knows of somebody
um
who
i'll give that a couple minutes
i don't want to cut any member of the
public from the public hearing
um
we do give those kinds of courtesies
when we're in the same house somebody's
out at the hallway waiting to come in or
something like that
representative baker is that
the honorable dancing styles trying to
former senator nancy styles is trying to
this
she indicates to me that it's it says uh
she's it's telling her that it's closed
she's the only one having that problem
there are at least nine attendees
and
while the script does say if the public
cannot get on that is the entire public
i will give her another couple of
minutes
we do have
um
i was provided a copy of her written
[Music]
representative graham if uh if she's
just trying to sign up to testify then
the registration for that would be
closed but she should be able to access
it through the public link
um if um someone's able to send me her
email i can always send her the public
link and see if she can come in that way
if you would and michael if
representative edgar if you are in touch
with her
tell her to go to the house tower and
uh thank you mr chair she uh
she was trying to do it that way uh if
if you received her um
uh testimony um would it be possible for
you to read it i can't find a copy
myself i know it was very brief
um
i believe that would uh
handle the uh then your situation or
i can
i i i have it
and and i will read it
for
for the record
and also
uh
it came in late yesterday evening
so it may not have gotten out to
everybody yet if not i will make sure
that every member gets it
it's a letterhead from the hampton beach
area commission
uh dated march 15 2021. their
representative brandt and capital budget
committee members for the record i am
nancy stiles
on behalf of the hampton beach area
commission hbac
i write in support of des requests for
funding the coastal flooding
model proposed in hb-25
hvac is in the process of updating its
master plan it's directed by new
hampshire's rsa
2 26
2 1 2
2 1 6
j colon 3
commerce ii and in particular we are
working on the environmental components
of that plan having just completed the
transportation component update
this past february hbac hosted a
symposium by cultural resilience with
100 virtual attendees in which there
were 13 presenters from different
organizations local state and federal
that had been studying our coastal issue
it would be most important to have our
new hampshire des holding the
organizational need to direct the
modeling as we move forward to protect
our precious resources this will assist
hpa cities with draft language for this
update as we live with water while
protecting our businesses safe
properties and wrestling i respectfully
ask to develop a capital budget this
year
funding
that includes funding for ds modeling
thank you for all that you do to protect
new hampshire's beautiful resources and
for the citizens of new hampshire nancy
styles changed chair hbac
i think it's pretty self-explanatory as
i said i will make sure that coffee gets
up to
everybody
representative edgar have a question
i i had a comment to you sir uh thank
you very much chairman for reading that
now we don't want to cut
any member of the public
off from any of that
despite the
zoom nature of these hybrid meetings we
do want to make sure that the public has
the opportunity to comment
i had no one else who had signed up
previously
to testify on house bill 25
i see nobody
who is in attendance
uh with their hand raised wishing to it
um
justified
last call for anybody
of the public who wishes to testify on
house bill 25a
uh make uh an act to make an
appropriation for capital improvements
going once
seeing that
the public hearing on house bill 25 is
closed
and as calendars suggested we're going
to go immediately into our work session
for the committee
at one o'clock
those
agencies that we have asked to come back
and and answer some additional questions
we'll be here to answer those questions
if there's not a full-blown presentation
from them it is to answer specific
first up
what i would like to do
is last friday
there was some committee
that met
on concerning
lapse extension request
that was shared by representative party
jack
um and he has prepared a report which
went out to all of the members
but i'd like him to go over that report
for the edification not just of the
members
but also
anybody who is attending this
uh hearing virtually
represent jack thank you mr chairman i'm
going to come over here so that i'm on
camera
as the chairman mentioned on friday the
12th
we held a subcommittee with myself and
representatives mills newman and corey
we took
uh
old testimony
and presentations from some agencies
we took other information
by email from other agencies
and the purpose of this is to call
it's to go through the locks extension
list in section 14 of household 25
and identify any items
that are there that are complete and can
be removed
and also identify any items that are
missing from there and need to be added
and we also
take testimony on
the projects that are complete that have
funds remaining
and we are able to reuse that money
representative jack confusions central
is everybody able to hear representative
jack
shake your head yes or no
okay thank you
with your back to those of us at the
front that's
your muscle that's all right we can't
make out what you're saying continue all
right
so i will just uh i did send this out in
written form to the committee
uh so i will just go through what we
found in section 14.
we delete line 55
we delete line 109 and there are 288 000
and liquor funds remaining in that
appropriation
there uh delete line 134
release line 138 and there are 47 793 in
general funds remaining
elite line 140
elite line 141
elite line 187
and elite line 190 with 19
646 of general funds remaining
we found two items that are missing
uh we need to extend the appropriation
that started in 2013
for unspecified minor military
construction for the edges in general
and also for the engine general we need
to extend the appropriations that began
in 2015
the presentations we learned that two
agencies were requesting that their
funds be repurposed
the department of environmental services
requested a repurpose of 161 890 through
the coastal flooding monitoring modeling
projects
and they supply
proposed language i don't believe we'll
actually need to use that
the department of safety
requested a repurpose of seventy four
thousand dollars to fire academy hvac
upgrade
now it's important to note these are
fire academy funds
uh the fire apparatus is ordered so we
know the cost of it has not yet been
delivered
uh they had another project to do the
hvac upgrade that was short of funds
because
the bid came in above what the amount
that was appropriated
uh if we were to do this uh it would
enable us to get the fire truck
which is on order and it would also
enable them to have enough money
in fire funds
to do the hvac project
the lba recommends amending the original
appropriate leading the last extension
for these funds and amending the purpose
which would be in hospital 25
of 2019 uh
section
romans 15
and b to read fire academy new truck and
hbac upgrade
for one million two hundred thousand
dollars
and uh
i will know
i want
since these are fire funds and and uh it
enables them to finish the project
uh this is my personal opinion i will
recommend that the committee adopt this
and include that language in house bill
uh the next item would be that we
located
2.233
million 117 dollars
in general fund appropriations from
completed projects
that are available for re-purpose and i
won't go through all the all the
agencies that's in the written report
uh
the biggest item is the department of
administrative services
at 1.7 million
and uh when it comes time the committee
amendment will
repurpose these funds to other uses
and uh
you could look in prior capital budgets
to see how that's done we did find one
error in one of the agency presentations
uh but that's the material to hospital
25.
thank you representative jack
are there any questions
from
members of the committee on the report
party
just started making sure
on that final statement you made
there's 2
that
projects are completed
in
general fund
um
from federal fund appropriations that
can be repurposed for other projects as
we go forward to this budget
that's correct the let's uh chris from
the legislative budget assistance office
uh
produced those numbers and i went
through and manually reconfirmed
from the information that was supplied
by the agencies that those those figures
are correct
thank you and i agree with them
last friday i know that is
time-consuming exhaustive
to trying to pin down all the agencies
on what they do with
prior appropriations but it is a useful
exercise
having done it myself and i do
appreciate that
at this point
see no questions of representative jack
i would ex
accept the motion that the report of the
subcommittee be approved
so
i'll second that
move by representative thompson
uh seconded by representative clutier
that the report
of the subcommittee
be approved and that includes his
comments about
um what agencies the couple agencies
that like the fire academy that wanted
to repurpose their money
would be part of
our hospital 25
we will decide what to do with the uh
two plus million
motion
seconded
any questions
seen that the clerk will call the roll
if you're in favor of accepting the
subcommittee report you will say i
you're opposed to say nay
representative mcconkey by
the clerk folks yes
representative sumero
yes hi
representative
yes
representative newton
aye
representative
representative boards
aye
representative kaczynski
yes
representative thompson
aye
representative clutier yes
hi
representative eagle
yes and thank you to the subcommittee
representative abbott
yes
representative faulkner
representatives newman
yes
i'm sorry
representative representative grassy
votes yes thank you sir
representative peterson
yes
representative clary
representative bunker
yes
sir
[Music]
chair of the vote is 20-0
yes
on the committee
um this is not a new procedure we have
done this several times in the past but
at this point we're usually just taking
a voice vote on accepting that the
subcommittee report but because of
the nature of our meetings now
anything like that as i said in the
done on a roll call
with that we have
some time
uh
my intention today
is to go through agency by agency
the compare report
prepared by the lba
we started using this on our last work
session
and
we will begin
and go through them all
after we have heard
from
the agencies if there are any changes we
can go back to
them back to uh each a
section
but if we don't start moving forward
we're not going to get an amendment done
in time
for the deadlines that we have because
as we change anything um
and if all of the committees
having the same
suspense now of uh first of april
uh uh legislative services is going to
and a very dedicated
staff at the legislative services but
still it's a time fulfilling process
the other chairman who is who would be
chairman of sitting here nodding their
heads
okay
first up
our department of administrative
services
for a total of 24
million 225 000.
is there any discussion on their
request
comments
and and
representative evil and i i will say
this is a work session
we're going to be a little less formal
if i call you by your first name
um don't be offended
people listening it's not because we
don't know why if i
don't i just
just the way it works
all right
okay john
um i just want to say that since the uh
the commissioner of doit is coming in
later um uh
i will be asking him my plan is to ask
him about the 5.1 million
appropriation
okay
as i said
i'd like to
put an asterisk next to that one subject
to what
the commissioner of doit says
but i'd like to
just put that aspect quite approve all
the rest of that
thank you has any objection
excuse mr chairman
under i said that
yes thank you mr chairman and mark i
apologize we're under administrative
services yes was there was there a
discussion that i missed on item 23
a statewide emergency
the surplus of 750 000
if i remember correctly during testimony
to possibly reducing that 1.5
million
uh representative jack was there any
money left in the emergency
[Music]
under das
did they provide you any information
about
fire
[Music]
thank you represent graham um the
department of administrative services
provided the committee through me a um
memo that showed what they had
for emergency funds i can show that to
you if you'd like
[Music]
so you should be able to see it and what
they've provided for you is with the
appropriation what they've spent the
money on
the various projects so
in the capital budget for 2021 the
current um budget that we're in there
was an appropriation of 1.5 million
dollars
of which they've spent 819 on the six
projects listed
and there's a balance remaining of six
hundred and eighty thousand dollars
they've
completely spent the amount that was
carried forward from the 1819 budget
that was 500 000
and that went towards the concord steam
conversion
so that that's the information they
provided on the emergency fund that they
thank you mr chairman and thank you so
much for bringing that up on the screen
so it would appear that um
[Music]
steam project is complete
uh and that there's a balance of 819.
mr chairman would it be appropriate to
speak of reducing
the 1.5 million to
it is appropriate and the committee can
do whatever we want with the numbers
that the governor have provided
understanding that if
when we do things like that
thank you mr chairman
i appreciate the fact that uh the state
is self-insured
and i would like to see that there's a
healthy balance there
and i i'm suggesting that we reduce the
1.5 million
by 500 000 so that we might possibly
meet the needs of some critical uh roofs
and so forth
uh and it would appear that it would
leave
1.819
in that fund
so i know if i need to do that as a
motion or for conversation
conversation at the moment thank you sir
680 left the way i'm reading this
um
oh i i apologize 680. sorry mr chair the
other one that's been fully spent yeah
i'm reading that right
you are um so there's 680 000 remaining
from the appropriation made in 2021 for
fun
it would still leave them once thanks to
thank you mr chairman i i would make a
motion
uh to reduce line 23 statewide emergency
fund from the governor's proposal of 1.5
million dollars
until we have the completed amendment
but we have
in the past and we will continue to do
it
um
so our votes on each agency as we're
going forward and line items that we may
again normally we could do this with the
weight slope however
any questions or comments representative
yeah so this is just a straw vote if we
did this we could revisit this right we
i think i'd be willing to do it for now
but i want to see what else you know
because i know we got a lot of projects
so
but if we you know and i don't know how
the rest of the metric i was coming to
so i think i will support it for now but
i couldn't
deserve the right to maybe change my
yes thank you mr chair i just want to
clarify so the emergency fund really is
the emergency fund and it's a backup
fund so if they're are calamities they
they can immediately have access to
monies to repair them
but
and the fact that we uh self-insured we
but there have been times in the past
where
severe damage due to a storm that we
hadn't spent money quickly to
fix it
and that's why we continue to put this
kind of money into
an emergency fund
and we continue it from miami to miami
just so that we can but
it is for emergency
and if we need to do it use it for
something else they have to come before
the legislative either
standing or statutory committees to do
that
um thank you uh i plan to support this
at this point um but i would guess that
das had some of the problems other
agencies have had in expending funds
as needed because of covid so
anyway thank you very much
any other
comments or questions on this motion to
reduce
uh statewide emergency fund
point five million to one million
dollars mr chairman
so as i understand that that's going to
add the 680 000 to the million
yeah so
we're actually increasing the amount
they want
well oh all right so
because
if you extend the laps of 680
and give them 1.5 then they have 2 over
it depends
to on what calamity
state buildings
and one year there was a building
collapse that we had to shore up walls
and stuff which was a warehouse
it was useful we did it done quickly
and they do
have to
start doing some of it they have to
report
is my memory wrong did we not ask
someone in one of the
um
department hearings to look at the
the cost of having that million dollar
deductible
what the difference was i don't remember
which agency it was but i know we asked
someone to come back to us and tell us
why it was
a million dollar deductible and what's
the difference
in the cost the insurance would be to
drop that
i'll try to remember the answer and i
don't think we got
clarification
we didn't at the time
mr chairman yes we did ask the question
and someone was reporting back and i
apologize i can't tell you yeah i can't
even
wasn't there looking back at the 2019
capital budget
originally as i under read it this is
called the lba information the governor
requested
2 million 250 000 we cut it in the house
to 1.5 million and the senate went along
with it and they've got extra money so
i'm willing to support this at least for
now
based on past experience and hopefully
the past experience will
continue in this lecture
so that's one reason why i'm willing to
so you know
philadelphia
yeah yes
representative newton
aye
representative blasey
representative boards
i
representative kaczynski
yes
representative kolansky
representative thompson
aye
representative bandy castillo
representative claudia yes
representative edgar aye
representative evil aye
representative abbott
yes
representative faulkner
representative newman
yes
representative grassy
representative peterson
yes
representative query
bonker
yes
representative graham yes
and um last work session we dealt with
the department of agriculture markets
and food for 180 000
for
uh our building at the eastern states
tech position
everybody was okay with it at that point
any
nobody want to change their mind see
nobody does
i would like to bring up
before we go on the corrections
one
that is the turning
from ports and harbors 1.5 million
i would accept the motion that we
include
that money
in this capital budget
mr chairman
do you need a second into that or maybe
i can't make them okay mr chairman would
like to make the motion to include uh
1.5 million dollars
uh to add the uh late uh entry project
of the turning basin
uh in light of the importance to our
economy
mr chairman if i could second that
please
been moved the second year that we had
five million dollars to
the
this leverages uh several million
millions of dollars in federal aid from
the corps of engineers who will actually
be doing the work but we do have to have
our match for that
we had some previously
but the
sport came in
with an additional
requirement for another 1.5 million
like to ask everybody to support that i
will be voting yes because we need to
keep our harbor operational with larger
representative
you have your hands right oh okay i
didn't take it down from when i was
trying to make the motion okay
okay
any any comments on on this edition we
heard from mr marconi about the need
i thank you all that is request that's
fine how much federal funds with that
risk if we do not do this
and
we i wish to thank our congressional
their uh out behind their desk let's put
it that way to actually get this done
but we need to match it or it's not
yes
representative
yeah
representative dolphy
yes
representative newton
representative
representative kaczynski
yes
representative
representative thompson
yes
representative clutier yes
representative edgar aye
representative ebal
yes
representative jack
representative abbott
yes
representative faulkner
uh yes and i have to leave the meeting
temporarily i'll be back
thank you representative newman
yes
representative
representative peterson
yes
representative query
representative bunker
yes
at this time i would accept the motion
that
if the report that we approve from
uh the subcommittee on lapse extension
there is 1.75
million dollars left over from
department of administrative services
i would i would ask for a motion at 1.5
million of that
they used to pay for the turning basin
which would make a net
mr chairman
uh representative jack moved it yep
representative
secretary
any any discussion on this
as you s what we are doing
with this motion if it is approved
and makes it in not the final version of
bill 25 is meeting this critical need
with money that had been appropriated
previously that we will repurpose for
this final project
so mr chairman repurposing money for the
turning basin were taken out of the
okay they left us from the previous
budget right from the three weeks okay
thank you mr chair representative
mcconkie bye
yes
representative newton
representative kaczynski
yes
representative thompson yes
representative cluja yes
representative edgar aye
representative ebal
yes
representative jack
representative abbott
he took off representative newman
yes
representative brassy
representative peterson
yes
representative query
representative funker
yes
and
chairman graham yes
chair of vote passes 18-0 thank you
again this is a smart vote i'm subject
to
our final approval with the amendment uh
to hospital
but
we will move on
second up is department of corrections
their trainer under the government's
true power tools 11 million
any questions about any of the
individual
items on there
representative
mr chairman
i would like to make a motion
to add uh
two projects on here that were not uh
previously funded by the governor
would this be the appropriate time this
would be the appropriate time right mr
chairman i would i would move that we
i believe my numbers are correct here
add 139
i think
if you look at what they requested their
next two priorities were
um
board the next prison for two hundred
thousand
and close custody needed for three
hundred thousand dollars except for fine
items
uh
okay thank you mr chairman thank you for
the correction
knowing how important it is for our
guests to have doors at work and the
people that are there to have doors at
work i would like to add that whatever
for that purpose
and second item would be
and looking at their presentation that's
where they're next to
priorities
i believe so mr chairman
okay i will second that motion
been moved and seconded that to the
department of corrections
we have two projects one is doors at the
men's prison for two hundred thousand
dollars that's not that they don't have
doors
wow
and a second project for the close
custody units for three hundred thousand
a total of five hundred thousand
added to this bottom line if we approve
those two new projects
and i won't
ask for any comments or questions from
anybody
with a strong stronghold
representative mcconkey aye
clerk votes yes
representative samara
yes
representative philadelphia
representative newton
yes
representative blasic
representative boards
representative kaczynski
yes
representative kolansky
representative thompson
yes
representative andy castillo
representative
yes representative edgar aye
evil
yes
representative jack
representative abbott
yes
representative faulkner
representative newman
yes
senator grassy
yes mr chairman my camera has stopped
working i don't know what the problem is
i'll try to reboot when i get a chance
here but i vote yes
democracy that's fine it's freaking here
your
portrait is
represent peterson
yes
representative query
representative bunker
yes
trevor
[Music]
extensions
the department of corrections had 60
from a
fire appropriation that was about to
collapse
i would accept the notion that that be
applied to the 200 000
that as
we just approved for the
course at the moment's prison
that would reduce that
saturn second
representative mills
followed by second by representative
county
great discussion on reducing that
appropriation by a lapse amount of six
it's a nine mr clark
thank you mr chair representatives
i'm missing raised hands so much i can't
tell you
representative mcconkey aye
representative mills the clerk votes yes
representative samara
yes
representative
philippe yes
representative newton
yes
representative blasic
representative boards
representative kasinsky
yes representative klatsky
representative thompson
yes representative mandy castillo
representative clutier yes
newman
yes representative
yes
representative peterson
representative clary
yes
representative bunker
chairman graham yes
now i know that we have asked the
commissioner of corrections to come back
this afternoon
to talk specifically about
sewer line and blinder and any other
questions we may have
but for now
i will accept that
with those additions
uh two projects
we are okay with the department of
corrections to be revisited after
uh be here in the commission
is there any objections from any members
when we run a lot
department of education
they had two items
a uh generator installation at the
walker building which was totally
federally funded
and tree engineering technologies for
three hundred thousand
we had located that at our last board
section
second thoughts on what we had agreed to
with that
scene i believe that
um representative eagle has a motion
yes she does mr chair i would like to
move that
we add to the education budget um the
refurbishment of the women's
bathroom in the um
in their building i'm sorry i don't
recall the name of it uh to in the
second okay
the move consecutive that we add
our refurbishment our renovation of
ladies
restroom at the department of education
for a total of six hundred thousand
dollars
i know
that this is not the first biennium that
the commissioner is after that
we will
thank you mr chair representative
mcconti
aye
yes
representative
representative newton
yes
representative klasik
representative sports
representative kaczynski
no
representative thompson
yes
representative clutier yes
representative edgar i
representative evil
yes
jack
representative abbott
yes
representative newman
representative grassy
yes
representative peterson
representative query
yes representative bunker
yes
representative graham yes
again subject to revisiting when we
have the final
vote on
what the
the department of education had 132
491 dollars
uh that from prior appropriations that
was about collapse
i would accept the motion that that
amount be applied to this project uh
renovation
[Music]
you know we
and if that were to be approved the new
additional funding would be 467
i'll second it
just so i'm clear representing graham
you you want to split this a new
appropriation between
um a new appropriation in house bill 25
and repurposing
an amount of existing
appropriation
and then repurposed
and change that they had from
if you can do it um it may cause some
confusion when people are trying to kind
of keep track of the project because
you'll have an appropriation in two
different places
um
why only a piece of what's remaining of
the repurposing amount and not the
entire
which
where are you looking
well
just to make sure i guess i'm trying to
make sure i have everything so the
department of correction projects both
of those were those repurposed funds the
200 and the 300
directions there is only 60
just just for clarity when you don't
need to um align with an agency's
lapsing to a new project you can use the
whatever is you want to repurpose for a
the agency may be lapsing from an
existing project
um so i i
thought the department of corrections
you had voted to
um fund
both the new projects from the
repurposing dollars i guess i might have
missed that
i think we did it only for once it was
such a small amount we did the actual
vote mr was first
to repurpose the uh
department of corrections center lapse
for 16
okay i didn't catch all that you were
breaking up representative mills
but that's all that's okay at the end of
this um maybe through a phone call or an
email we can clarify a few things
if i have
to
sorry to interrupt
oh okay relax yeah
dude
one
representative mcconkey hi
folks yes
yes
uh yes
senator newton yes
representative
yes
okay
representative
nope i had my second
representative thompson
yes
representative danny casteel
representative claudia yes
representative edgar i
representative ebal
yes
representative jack yeah
representative abbott
representative newman
yes
representative grassy
representative
peterson
yes
representative querrey
representative bunker
yes
chair the motion passes
um
next up department of environmental
services
at our last work session we agreed on
everything that the governor had to
close
with the exception and we wanted some
more information at least a discussion
with uh commissioner oit
uh about the one stop i-t system
upgrades
anybody wish to change their mind on
that
um
i know that
representative edgar probably had to
function
thank you mr chairman yes yes i do
uh i would like to to make a motion to
fund the
coastal flooding model
uh at this time
i will uh make the motion for 162
dollars
a thousand dollars and um with the uh
ability possibly to
increase that later when we get to the
very end but the motion is for 160
thousand dollars to fund
a
for a second for that amount
i'll second it
okay the more consecutive
[Music]
the department had requested
that they have 161
um that was about collapse that they
said that they could use for this
project that they could
do with that amount
um
unless
i
are you willing to go to that amount or
um
i i just rounded their 100 and i thought
161 up to 100 because it was 161 ate
some
i just said 162. so
rodney that you started adding to the
bottom line
uh we can go with exactly what they say
that they are uh
lapsing which
okay which is 161 890
yes i'll make that yes let's use that
figure then sir that's what you'd like
to do
so the motion would be to repurpose
um
last money from the department of
environmental services of 161
that
the way you would like to have it done
oh yes mr chairman thanks
okay
representative mccarthy uh thank you mr
chairman uh it was nice to hear from our
past senator rasales this morning
i want to be supportive of
representative edgar at this point
i'm going to vote in favor i believe
i'm not totally uh sold on this project
i'm most likely when we're done look at
a lesser number so that we can get this
project started but at this point i will
any other comments on this or questions
mr chairman
thompson um
having been
a coastal contractor for the last
20 years and
the
mean tides rise almost 19 inches in the
i think that
whatever money we spend in this study
uh is money well spent
i know there was a governor's commission
report
done a number of years ago by the new
england governors
i've read that report and it recommended
that all states raise their sea walls
and then
feed immediately
to deal with the global warming and
the effects we're going to have from
that
and i've i've seen the flooding in the
hampton
and rye areas on a
almost weekly basis some summer
and i think there certainly needs to be
some money put into this to figure out
how to
thank you um
do you think that there lacks money to
continue on with this and which does not
add to our bottom line of generally
funded projects
the bottom line to where we are
any of these line items can be
represented but for now call of all
please thank you for repurpose
uh 160
thank you mr chair mr mc representative
mcconkie hi
folks yes
representative camaro
aye
representative dolphy
yes
representative knew
representative
representative boards
yes
representative
representative thompson yes
representative castille
representative clutier yes
representative edgar aye
representative ebal
representative jack
representative abbott
representative newman
yes
representative grassy yes
representative peterson
yes
representative quarry
representative bunker
yes
sheriff
mr chair of motion passes 19-0
thank you
um the next agency is the fish and game
commission
[Music]
at our last work session
we agreed to the sum of four million six
hundred fifteen thousand
um
has anybody changed their mind or want
hhs
what the governor has proposed
is a total of
uh 25 million 971
000 nine dollars
in generally funded
projects for
the department of
health and human services
anybody have questions or comments about
any individual
project on this
understanding that a large portion of it
is funded
on
his matching funds
later this afternoon since a lot of
their
we can hold off on the final vote
um
so i vote even on
health and human services
until we hear about that
we may
in addition to what's in here
representative
mr chairman
i believe the
wilkins building is part of this
there was a cost of a
proposal to demolish
a failing building
i'd like to propose that we had i
believe the number is 750 000 dollars uh
to the bottom line for the demolition of
that building
have a second name
okay
if i remember correctly
that building has fired and it's
currently unusable
a security fence around it but it is a
uh
chasm shall we say to
we are going to need to do something
about that state building in the middle
of
the queen city
is
as i said a nuisance i'm not
we can ask when they they come this
afternoon what what their plans are but
at this point uh
any questions about appropriating
750 000
to remove
um
and was it something that that the
department
didn't get in the governor's budget
right that is correct all right i just
can't seem to find it
it it is um
under hhs
i think it's towards the end it's one of
their quality priorities
[Music]
yes thank you um i i do plan to support
this mr chairman but i'm very interested
to hear what hhs has to say about the
sununu center and what their overall
plan is because
some of the
buildings that are deteriorating are
external to the main center and
it just will be good to find out what
they have in mind for those things as we
sort of put our precious dollars out
there thank you
i i think that
no matter what representative people
even if we were
by some stretch of the imagination to
close that center
we still have the responsibility to
to take care of the uh
i think you're right mr chair
uh
so
the motion is to add
the demolition of the wilkins building
under hhs
any discussion further discussion
seeing that for
representative mcconkey hi
the clerk votes yes
sumero
yes
representative newton
yes representative blasic
representative boards yes
representative kaczynski
yes
representative thompson yes
representative castillo
representative clutier yes
representative edgar
aye
representative ebal
yes representative jack
representative abbott
yes
representative newman
representative grassy yes
represent peterson
yes
representative quarry
representative bunker
yes
motion is that in here
um mr chairman i believe there's an
additional need to replace a boiler
and
a long-standing
policy of
taking care of
heating and roofs i would like to move
that i do not see my number in front of
me mr chairman
can you help me with that
what i have from their presentation is a
hundred thousand dollars
and i would
uh
ask you to admit that that we scoop up
some money
that is left from health convenience
services
information technology national cultural
resources and the veterans fund
for
just a little over a hundred thousand
dollars to pay for that
so that we do not
uh
have any new funding going towards
i thank you mr chairman i would move
invitation
any
comments or questions about doing this
again
hhs will be here this afternoon
we can ask more about that
but moving on
for the moment
let's see that and the appropriation
of new generally funded
uh monies would be zero
you need a second mr chair
i think i heard what
okay
this is wrong
details as for clarification what are we
talking about
the boy
and
i think it was their number one uh
unfunded priority in their presentation
great
and it is a zero-sum game in lots of
ways
i think that
we can try but if you will look at um
what uh representative mcconkey is is
suggesting we use to pay for this
collapses
so it's a little over
a hundred thousand just in case that
that estimate is not correct
uh i would if it cost more than that
they'll have to come back to us
okay representative mcconkie hi
folks yes
represent samara
hi
representative
yes
representative newton
representative
representative boards aye
representative kaczynski
yes
rosario velansky
representative thompson yes
representative mandy castillo
representative clutier yes
representative edgar all right
representative evil
yes
representative jack
representative faulkner
representative newman
yes
representative grassy
representative peterson
yes
representative querrey
chairman graham
chair the motion passes
19-0
traditionally we finished with
admin services until we hear from oit
about
projects that deal with information
technology i would remind the committee
on health and human services
that what we heard about some of these
ip projects
they need to get done because we are
already being fined
by the federal government for not having
these systems up
and if we can avoid uh long-term uh
repayment of stuff to defense
uh it's probably a good thing
that's about operating funds
monthly or reportedly i forget what the
exact
the department did not ask for anything
more
so unless there is an objection
we should accept what they asked for
something to hear it from the
commissioner
that was for six million
um
i'll make a motion that we accept that
amount
we just
okay
approved the 1.4 million dollars for
the national report
for a continuation of that project
um
liquor commission our last
approved
one million dollars for
uh
credit card point of service that is
other not parts general it comes out of
their fund
and they
said that they could
some recommended changes from
um
in his testimony
uh
his priority for
the anti-terrorism
uh force protection
which had 415 000
uh generally funded bonds
matching 1.245
million in federal funds
he stated that that was all going to be
federally funded now clean up 415
dollars
we
would ask that we we
take that money
and put it against uh
readiness center renovations
uh which would be funded at six hundred
thousand dollars
um
there is
money left over from the 1.7 million
we could match the uh the fourth
we would still have the 415 000 that was
there but match the the
remaining 185
from lapses
so i would accept the motion that would
do that
um no i think that's what that's what i
wanted you to do i was hoping we were
doing that it sounds
good it will not change the bottom line
and uh
right now in the department for what we
are
using for a general funded portion of
uh his request because everything else
was to
change the 415 000
to uh
readiness and revelation statewide
as outlined in his proposal
from his testimony
and we would match it with some
repurposed money so that he gets the six
hundred dollars that he needs
to match uh six hundred thousand across
federal funds
yes
representative newton yes
representative
representative boards
aye
representative kasinsky
yes
representative representative thompson
representative castille
representative clunia yes
representative edgar all right
representative eval yes
representative jack representative
abbott
yeah
representative faulkner
representative newman
yes
representative
representative peterson
yes
representative query
representative bunker
yes
mr chairman yes
chair of the vote is 19-0 in favor of
the motion
is there
all of the rest from that department is
federally funded
are there any questions
that anybody has that needs to be
addressed on those
projects
i will accept that
we
without that change
are in agreement on military therapy
services
from total uh fairly funded portion of 4
million
83 000
dollars
with uh federal funding of 1.15 million
for chartered golden afterwards any
questions or comments on what is
representative thompson
revisiting their uh budget request for
cannon mountain
um
i've spoken with tom mansfield over
there over the last few days recently as
this morning
and
the
the life of the cannon mountain tramway
is
i think was originally
calculated 30 years it's at the 42-year
mark now
if we were to
find a way to come up with 6.25 million
dollars to
do this project
um it would take three years
from the time we give them the money
and
they need the money in order to place an
order with the company that
designs and builds these
facilities
um
it would take two years
to design build it
and get it shipped here from
i don't remember it's denmark or france
but
um and then another year
to erect it
um
we take in about 1.5 million dollars a
year in revenue from that operation
uh probably a new more efficient system
would bring in more
and it seems like the payback of that
is
maybe a maximum of four years
and
it's really something we need to look at
if we don't get it into this budget
um it's gonna wait another two years
and it'll put it five or six years down
well
i see your hand uh representative abbott
but this is probably a good time for me
to bring this up
in my current um
american rescue plan i think it's the
budget uh
government plan that was passed and
president bond assigned to the wow last
week
there is
122 million dollars
coming to new hampshire
for state capital projects
um so some of the needs that we are
talking about will be
i don't know what the strings are on
that it is not here yet the guidance has
not been provided to the state debt on
how to use that money but it will come
and i have been told
um by the
governor's budget director that that it
will be nine laps in money meaning that
will not have to be spent this calendar
well i am supportive of the need to fix
the tramway and replace it
i'm not sure i don't see how we can find
six million
plus
i don't know what they would need to to
do even preliminary design on it
they need they need the total funding
available to commit to that company to
get them to do the design work out there
that i understand
where it fits into
our winter sports
and the fact that it is useful
and it does bring in before uh parts and
directive and natural resources
but to add six million to um
take this up
[Music]
i understand i'm just pleading the case
right
is the money that's coming from the
federal government is that going to come
through this committee or is that going
to be that that is something that is
unknown i have asked the governor's
office that we'd be
uh at least
um
at the table when it is decided by the
extent
it may come in the fiscal committee to
be used
as a lot of federal grants are
but that is something that is unknown
i personally believe that
representatives of
this community senate capital uh budget
committee
uh should be part of the negotiations on
how to do that
there is
obviously a commission in house bill 2
to for the
forensic psychiatric hospital
for some 17 million dollars
that would either be
paid with federal funds or finally
that's outside of where we are right now
i've responded as an
to this
um
that i think that uh
the governor the senate or even
house finance if they could get a hold
of the money would use would use part of
that 122
for that purpose but i would still leave
almost an entire capital election
right for youth and i think that having
listened
to all of the
uh presentations
from all of the agencies over the last
month or so
that we are in good standing as to make
recommendations on how that
money should be spent and we can work as
a committee to prioritize
unfunded uh needs
and that to me that would be one of them
because it does it is a jewel in uh
our outdoor activities
it's just it's
the biggest attraction in northern new
hampshire
aside from the from the uh
the fact that we're a tourist state
self-proclaimed
it also provides rescue
capabilities that we don't have
otherwise in weather conditions and
access to the communication system
that's on top of it
yeah year round right use of that
tramway is it was
eye-opening to be at least the numbers
for
uh summer and fall especially and i
pointed out to
tom the other day that you know it's not
just the 6.2 million we're going to lose
the tramway for a year
so we're going to lose a million yeah
while it's down
so it's actually a 7.5 million dollar
commitment
and
i'm
yes thank you mr chairman
um
i
in the presentation uh
um
i just wasn't really comfortable with
the way it was
presented and when asking about the
controls
from the tram
and whether the department of
information technology had been
consulted
and the response was no and i just think
in terms of the planning i'm not opposed
to
the tram
but i think that
the plan
needs to be
crystallized a little bit more
and you know how it would be approached
and
that's just the way i feel about it
i am i've been listening i have a
question
okay look forward to having
this additional federal money
or capital projects
if we were to
indicate our desire to go forward with
something like the tramway
and we put a dollar in the hospital 25
to say and then with words in our board
by extended committee report that says
we support this and the federal funding
um
you could you could put a note in so
essentially that's what they did in
house bill 2 with the um youth
uh the forensic unit
that was structured in a way to say if
there's federal dollars that can be used
to do that
then that will be the first dollars that
shall be used and then they added the
capital appropriation
um
you could make a statement
in i don't know if i would put a dollar
in a line
but you could admit i think you could
probably include a section that says
um you know if federal dollars were to
become available you know the the
committee's priority of projects would
be a b and c but i'd run that by the
drafting attorneys
i think that we would like to
put something
looking around the committee
at least on the tramway for them to look
we can revisit this and when we get some
some words and figure out what we can do
now it does not mean that it will
survive
could we appropriate some amount of
money
to allow them to study it and come back
with a proposal like
representative abbott is well and that's
what i i guess when i asked you that
question earlier
about if they have given you a number
for
what i said besides it didn't
necessarily mean that the
blueprints the timepiece but uh
um
what is it we need how much
they may already have all that uh if you
could check and we could
talk about it at my next uh
workstation
i think that there is enough interest on
the committee to
do something
even if it is only but our statement
that
we would
like to see something done with some of
but the rest of
cultural resource natural cultural
resources anybody have any problems with
what the government has proposed mr
chairman
thank you
thank you mr chairman
um i am
supportive of representative thompson's
thoughts on canada mountain but
with representative advent the chairman
i just don't know where we find that
funding unless the feds come in
but this this committee has had a long
stand policy
of funding critical needs for the state
parks
and i know that uh they approved their
funding but i would like to
raise uh raise the thought of adding 150
into this budget
for the purposes of critical maintenance
to be defined
by the department and approved by some
for that purpose
it's not enough if i could mr chairman
it's it's not an awful lot of money but
uh i can speak to uh white lake state
park uh in the area of my of my district
that even
a load of gravel uh not found in the
budget
for a year uh had people hopping up and
down just driving to the beach
so
like i said we've had a long-standing
policy from all the chairmen uh for all
the committees in the 18 years
and
that that i have had the pleasure of
serving here and i would just propose
that we would add at this point in time
150 000
uh to this budget for uh critical
maintenance
i will second that one
okay let me ask the question
is that in addition to
i
thank thank you for the question mr
chairman i don't know the answer at this
point
uh i'd like to plug that in or
um
because i'm looking at what they
uh
thank you mr chairman i would add 150
do you second that so
if not
it talks about every agency coming back
reporting how they're sending the money
approved
but the motion before us is to add
150 000
to natural cultural resources roofing
and repair environment
to raise it to 1.35
million dollars
[Applause]
representative
yes
representative newton
representative brycek
representative boards aye
representative kozinski
no
representative kolansky
representative thompson
aye
representative danny castillo
yes
representative jack
representative abbott
yes
representative faulkner
representative newman
yes
presenter degrassi
representative peterson
yes
representative query
yes representative bunker
yes
mr chair president
we have not discussed any of these any
other
questions about
natural and cultural resources is what
[Music]
nine
will tentatively accept those at our
last session
accepted
what police standards and training
council had
been
provided by the governor which is
1.325 million
discussion we move on
we also discussed the veterans home
for 1.46 million
and we
had no changes to that everybody's still
the governor proposed
2.55 million dollars
for ncc engineering technology and
renovation
the system came in with lists and then
revised lists of both critical
maintenance
and
as well as
some other projects that they would like
for example moving boiling to littleton
for uh
but
representative mccall
um mr chairman and thank you
i believe i have my number correct here
that
i'd like to propose that we add
1 million
to community college
budget
one million dollars for the community
college system for the purposes of
critical maintenance
and when i looked at
their revised presentation which
everybody should have
they're
they divided critical maintenance in the
two portions the first portion was just
right at one million dollars
so i would be supportive of doing that
and again
um i'll talk a little bit later
after we do this
any
any questions or comments
about adding one million dollars for
critical maintenance for the community
college system
yes is this far would be spent at all
campuses right now
there is no designated campaign in
campus
but every one of those campuses has
critical and or
life safety issues that need to be
impressed all right okay all right thank
you which one millionaire will put in
any other comments
support
representative mcconkey hi
yes
representative newton
representative
representative boards
aye
representative kozinski
yes
representative polanski
representative thompson yes
representative bandicas deal
representative claudia yes
representative edgar aye
representative eval
yes
representative jack
representative abbott
yes preservative faulkner
representative newman
yes
representative grassy
representative peter said
yes
representative quarry
representative bunker
yes
motion passes 19-0 mr chair
thank you that brings the total for
community college systems with that
probe to
3.55 million dollars
i
will say this
emails and etc from
members of the automobile dealer's
association as well as
some of us received from
about moving the
borrowing
diesel and other mechanics from bowman
to littleton
but the cost of that is five million
dollars to do that
as i have told a couple people who have
called me
i don't see how living within our means
we can do that at this point
i would suggest that perhaps when we
start talking about
adding a footnote into the capital
budget about federal funds
we would at least that portion of the
community colleges
if not more and we can talk about that
one at our next work session
because i think that we need to make it
clear to the people who
receive this money that we have some
thoughts on how to get spent
um and i don't think that anybody on
this committee disagrees with that
statement
um because we are the ones who have
worked
[Music]
these issues but we've also heard from
all of the agencies
so we may come up with a modified list
of what we think is truly critical and
and some of the stuff in the column
system is truly critical
moving forward
um regardless of whether or not
we
see what the governor is proposing about
the two
higher education systems
the buildings and programs still have to
i'll just leave it at that we can work
on
what we
what language and what we think needs to
at least be pointed out that we would
like to see the federal money because
that federal money may come in and be
i think again i am you know i really
don't think the senate should get all
the boards you know we should have a say
and unfortunately the senate comes after
us so sometimes they can
you know uh get do things that we we
can't or we were more cautious about it
fiscally
so and i just want to elaborate i
receive calls from people in my area and
i ask them why are you interested in
moving this from berlin to
littleton they said it'd be easier for
people to take courses
from even claremont because all they
have to do is hop on even though it's in
vermont 91 and it's faster than going to
berlin it saves about an hour
so they're lobbying me on this that i
can't promise at the time i didn't know
the amount you know but i said i made no
promises but if we could put in language
some of that federal money that would be
i used to be that would be great as far
as i'm concerned okay
we will have to
talk
i i'm against moving to college this
program from berlin to littleton
uh neither berlin nor littleton is in my
district
but um there are a lot of people that
come from the colebrook area
and errol and that that go to that
college um
specifically some of them to take the
diesel program
and for them to have to go to littleton
when we asked questions of the of the
doe when they were here to testify i
asked what percentage they thought
they'd increase their
their
school population by and said they
thought around 20
which tells me if you think it's around
20 you haven't done enough research
to find out what it is and spend 5
million
on a guess that that's going to be a
better program than one we already have
in place
particularly this
well
or comments about the community college
i know that they have
several requests into all of us
and they've done a lot of work they're
trying to narrow down what they need
but again
well it's not quite a zero-sum game it's
pretty close at this point
um
hopefully
uh
last at our last work session
we agreed to 750 thousand dollars which
yes uh thank you chairman
disability pleased to discuss the
uh repurpose it would be the separate
section
what that does is
allow them to
uh
i'm sorry
all right folks
in seconds um i would remind everybody
that that was presented as part of his
lapse
mr chairman but i couldn't understand a
word of what
representative jack was saying
neither could i know everybody else had
that problem too
out which you all got
that's on the second page
uh this
so i'm moving that we add a section to
hospital 25
that amends 2019 146 colon 1
roman 15b
we read b
fire academy new truck
and hvac upgrade for 1.2 million dollars
the effect of this is to say is to allow
them to use the 74 000 that is left over
from buying the fire truck on the hvc
upgrade
where the bid came in over what the
appropriation was and they haven't been
any questions
on
thanks
[Music]
yes representative sumero
i guess i just have a question
sir
we're doing the one with the fire now or
fire
yes i say yes on that one
representative philadelphia
yes
representative newton
senator blasey
representative boards yes
representative
yes
representative polanski
representative thompson
yes
representative castillo
representative clooney again
representative edgar aye
representative evil
yes
representative jack
representative abbott
yes
representative faulkner
[Music]
representative newman
yes
representative gracie yes
representative peterson
yes
representative querrey yes
representative bunker
yes
sharon graham yes
share the vote is 19 nothing in favor of
all right um our last work session
we did
um
agreed to
department of transportation generally
funded
uh
projects for 1.72
um
180 742 1022
yes
mr chairman
um there were two projects that i think
are important to be brought in as a
partial funding
uh which i believe is on the
transportation side of the railroads
[Music]
okay
if we could uh
finish with a vot and then we will talk
about
thank you mr chairman i withdraw my
motion at this time okay
highway funds
this
is an amendment to hospital 25 that has
been
drawn up on the last by name
you should all have a copy of that
uh
which
moves around
but it's a
highway-funded portion of it
it changes the bottom line
from
and it's all highway funds like
generally funded
this is something that
we had agreed to
when we were discussing what
the department had come in and asked to
do with
highway funding
and storage sheds the fuel management
system
and the rest
so i would
ask somebody
i'll do it uh
we have in front of you
and i would ask that
that be
unapproved until we improve it it will
have to be incorporated into the overall
because there's only one amendment that
can go forward
but that's what it is and it is what we
discussed
if the department is online i think they
are
if they have
they were
if they have any
comments or questions i would take them
at this time
about this i think it is what
yeah
did you bring him up
press score
good morning mr chairman yes um
the department has read the amendment
and we are
in support in total agreement with with
amendments so we very much appreciate
representative graham putting this forth
uh
sure yeah it's what we try to do we try
to work with
all of the agencies
but um
it changes that section for the
highway bonding but um
i think it
is clear on what we want to do with the
anybody have any further questions or
comments about that thank you very much
deputy christian right
all right
do you know further
dan's raised on this
amendment
[Applause]
yes
representative
representative newton
yes
representative lasik
representative kuczynski
yes
representative thompson
representative claudia yes
representative edgar all right
representative ebal
yes
representative jack yeah
representative abbott
yes
representative newman
represent brassy
yes
representative peterson
representative query
yes
18-0
most
and
there was one final section at our last
work session
we did discuss and
reached an agreement on the unh
university system 15 million dollars
anybody change their mind or want to add
anything to that at this point
seeing none
we've gone through every agent
subject to some
some changes maybe after we hear from
them
um
those agencies you've got to come back
in and see
with some of the changes we've made and
not all of that
um we are within
a couple
of hundred thousand dollars
of where the governor proposed in his
original budget despite adding
these projects
by adding
some other things
and we still have
some things we need to talk about
but overall we stayed pretty close to
the dollar amount that the government
proposed
which
well not a requirement
is still a good thing when we try to go
selling this to the total membership of
the house
representatives
which
okay
all right
we retained
two bills
uh to see if we could fit them into the
capital budget
uh
and we have the
agencies coming that one
i am going to
recess the committee until
pm
um so those of us who actually laid it
in the carpet into the room and go find
some place open or someplace to eat
the rest of you can squirt it out
wherever you go
when you do it too
but the committee will be in recess
until
uh 1 pm when we will be 12
the
agencies that we ask to come back and
talk about a couple of things
and then we will discuss the two
uh retain bills
and then
one final quick look at everything that
we've already done
and make sure that we're still all on
the same page
it is going very well i thank the
committee for
all of their hard work so far
and we're moving
along
quite well and i appreciate that
with that the committee is in recess
until
uh
yeah
okay okay
[Music]
1pm
i'd like to call the
public works and highways committee back
into
session
at this point some members of the
committee had asked
various members of agencies to come in
and discuss some things first one up i'd
like to bring um commissioner boulay of
doit
yep
so there have been
a couple of the members who have some
questions about
the overall magnitude that i see within
the capital budget
and uh
i believe some of them have questions
about maybe scalability or
what your thoughts are and i'll begin
thank you mr chair and uh good to see
you commissioner um and thank you for
all you've done the past year getting us
up and running and remote etc etc i know
it's been quite a hurdle
so as the chairman said when we look at
the
budget
35 million dollars of capital funds are
being
suggested by the governor to be
appropriated for it costs and as you
yourself
have observed and even the budget
director observed this is
a much bigger slice of the capital
budget than there has been in the past
and so
i just wanted to talk to you about
scalability on
some of them i mean we realized that the
dhhs
issues were going to get fined by the
federal government if we don't comply
but
there was some uh question raised by a
couple of people about the one stop uh
in the d
e s budget it was about five million
dollars
so that was one thing i was going to ask
you about
if there was any scalability there you
could discuss with us or maybe
since you have an idea of the overall
situation you could make some
suggestions so thank you
all right well
thank you representative ebel
glad to see you're back on the it
council we'll be uh we're going to have
a meeting pretty soon lots of good
topics um i'd like to first start i'm
going to
if the committee will indulge me for a
moment i will review the process
we went through to get to the governor's
budget and then i'll talk about some
some factors i think that led to where
we are today and then we can go into how
where we take it from here
um
so
the we did actually work with all the
agencies to develop their capital uh
technology related capital budgets and
we uh
we did um compare those to their
strategic plans to make sure that they
actually met uh
fit in with the plans
and and that we understood where each of
those projects stood in the overall
agency prioritization
we then um used a model we built we've
been using now it's our third biennium
using this model it's a kind of a
complex model i'd be happy to share it
with you folks sometime when you have a
bit more time but um
it really takes into a bunch of factors
like a potential impact on citizens
federal leverage for example is a big
one organizational readiness to do the
project is is a factor
um so you know the federal or the other
funds leverage kind of a big deal and
that's one of the reasons why you see a
lot of hhs projects rising to the top of
the prioritization
matrix
so
for the last couple of biennia the
governor has drawn a line in the
prioritized list he might
decide to tweak the prioritized list
and this this particular biennium that i
think what we put forward was what was
accepted by the governor
and um so i asked specifically in
anticipation of this hearing i asked the
governor's office specifically about you
know it's a big big jump in um
in dollars and you know
you know what's your number one reason
for that and and the the
answer was
pretty straightforward they you know
particularly in the light of the last
year or so that the recognition that
more than ever
technology is driving our citizen
services efforts
is reflective of what of the amounts
that the governor put forward as a
suggestion so that was the that was one
factor um another factor
is the overall uh technology density
which i think is really a core
corollary of the first factor it keeps
increasing in our agency partners you
know we keep
finding that you know adding technology
is the way to deliver uh citizen
services in in the world as we live in
it today
um there were another factor uh was um
you know last biennium was a long time
low
i actually looked back all the way as
far as i could find records i think it
was 10 11.
and last biennium was an all-time low
for technology projects which i think
probably created some pent-up demand in
this biennium to have more in larger
projects and and
and again a corollary to that
is that it did create some deferred
maintenance um
particularly in health and human
services where they had some things
where we've actually fallen off the
compliance curve and now we're either
getting find this this biennium or about
to get fined
we're not having remain compliant with
our whether with uh the requirements
from our federal partners um and and i
would actually say um environmental
services is one of those where we you
know we have some deferred maintenance
we those those systems in one stop are
um
you know they're from a technology
perspective they're pretty old some of
you may recall that we we actually we
did a cyber a statewide comprehensive
cyber assessment
uh last year and we found some issues
with some of our systems including one
stop and
what we found overall
in the state from an application
perspective was
the age of the technology um
had a direct relationship to the
likelihood that there might be cyber
vulnerabilities because the back in the
day when we were writing applications 25
years ago
people weren't worried about cyber
security very much back then and now
it's a big deal so
that i'd say on the one stop there's a
lot of opportunity to improve our
citizen service capabilities improve the
reliability of what we offer
and i think i think
commissioner scott
is here as well today so it might you
know at some point you know i'd like to
hear his take on it but from a business
perspective i know that he's very
supportive of it
now
i've been in situations plenty of times
where
a proposed budget isn't what gets passed
either in the private sector or in the
public setting as we're here today
there's really two ways of approaching
that if if it's the will of the
committee to reduce the amount of tech
spend in in the capital
budget then there's kind of a couple
ways one like uh is as rep people
mentioned scalability i'm assuming that
doesn't is not referring to scaling up
so um you know we can
we can make asks uh we can all go and
say talk to the agencies and say hey you
know
we need to sharpen our pencils a bit
here and
you know i thought about that a bit from
my own perspective from the from what
i've asked for
and um so
i think there's almost always potential
for scalability
um and then is you know are all of these
um you know with the committee
prioritize things in a similar fashion
as the governor um
we
um
you know we agree with the
prioritization we're the ones that came
up with it
um
there it may be that we
have to do a little less
in in this biennium and then and then
move some of that forward in a future
biennium i mean one of the challenges
with um
with health and human services is that
in order to get a good particularly on
those 90 10
projects to get a really good general
funds bump you have to take a really big
slice out of the project which isn't um
which isn't always going to be healthy
for the project so
so that's my those are my formal remarks
i'll follow up follow up mr chair
um
so i guess what i i would just ask um
for instance with the with the one stop
or any of these things if you took 300
000 off or 100 000 i mean does it really
affect the ability of the project to go
forward
um i i would think there's opportunity
in them
to
i've done that
many times in my career where you say um
hey let's
you know let's not cut projects but
let's scale them back a little bit and
then if you do it to all of them
in a similar way it actually turns into
a reasonable amount of money so you know
thank you i my my agency um counterparts
might not agree with me
i mean just the mere fact that uh doit
is presumptuous enough to uh prioritize
all of the agency projects against each
other versus treating them as stovepipes
is a little bit
you know is a little problematic so me
saying that
is based on my experience with doing
lots of budgets for you know decades and
decades and
i've found that you know if you need to
get if you need to get a little bit
lower then that that proportional effect
in combination with other things can can
well in the case of follow-up mr chair
in the case of des there's a coastal
flooding program that needs a maybe
another three hundred thousand dollars
so you know i just i was that was one of
the reasons i was asking
yeah and i would since the commissioner
scott he i believe was here i think uh i
would ask him to comment on whether he
would cut you know money elsewhere or
thank you
representative
in the projects that you manage
mr director
where um
where are we
just out of date
what ones of these projects are the most
critical
well the um
i'd say you know in terms of the total
dollars and impacts to citizens which is
how we prioritize
you know those hhs projects that
particularly like uh medicaid
uh mmis and and the other hhs projects
where
we're
compromising our ability to leverage
federal funds by not staying up to date
so that's one if you measure it that way
then those are pretty high priorities um
then if you say okay how where are we in
terms of being able to deliver
the citizen services that that are
expected then i think all of these
projects fall into that
that category that we do have a lot
of very outdated technology it's very
similar i mean i hear that we you hear
the same testimony
um from the building you know folks
talking about building and plant right
there you know whether it's a
it's a um you know septic uh system at
glencliff or whatever you know there's
there's a lot of deferred maintenance
and can we run systems in the state a
lot longer than
than i've ever seen systems run before
in my career and on average so 30 years
is not unusual uh the revenue system
that they're replacing now is over 30
years old liquors
you know point of sale and um
and back in the house processing that
associated processing is
pushing 30 years old so you know the
driver license system where you're
placed a couple years ago and dmv was
over 30 years old so it's pretty pretty
common now i'm i'm a big fan of running
systems for a long time to get the most
investment out of them
and so you know a decade maybe even 15
or 20 years might not be the wrong thing
to usually too much because you're then
you're you know you're you're past your
diminished diminishing points of return
and you're investing in something that
isn't worth investing in anymore
but it does cost money to replace
systems as you see so
i think that's my best generic answer to
that
representative
thank you mr chairman
um for the
commissioner um
i i uh for the chairman i i'm hoping
i'll be able to ask commissioner scott a
question later if they said he's out
there
okay thank you uh
so as far as processing payments to the
state i know that there are some
standalone systems
that we're told about
health and human services and some of
the others do we have the standard
platform
that that we use for the processing of
credit cards example if i could
example subsurface has a as a
as the ability to pay
fees online but the heritage bureau does
not
my understanding is that
with the part of the upgrade
commissioner scott's talking about that
they will take care of that
in the department supposedly going
forward but are we using the same
company or the same format
on all of our all of our our processing
i understand that could change in the
next six months but are we at least
doing that
across your platforms
um
well it starts with who's who's our um
the bank we're working with or the
entity we're working with to do the
credit card processing and that's a
that's a single statewide contract
currently with chase that uh department
of administrative services manages
and
in our credit card payments flow through
that the largest volume of those as you
might guess is from liquor
and liquor drives
liquor's volume drives our pricing for
back-end credit card processing and then
you look at well what is the use case so
if the use case for example with
with some of the if you have three
different applications that are taking
credit card processing and the vendor
built-in credit card processing into
that application but it may look
somewhat unique to the citizen even if
it's
the same back-end process as you
mentioned but our goal is to to have
as small number as possible of different
use cases that people have to absorb and
in your case you know the the fact that
you're dealing with a single agency with
a
single set of applications i mean it's a
reasonable expectation that
that
that we should be have a single look and
feel for the citizen it's all the same
on the back end generally speaking now
there's some variation there over the
almost six years i've been doing this
um you know if administrative services
changes over the company that's on the
back end
then it takes us a year or more to
switch all the agencies over so that
there's that
possibility on back end with being
different for a while but
thank you
welcome
and thank you i'd like to remain i'd
like to remain here just to support
commissioner scott if i know
but before i
call um commissioner scott up i do have
the treasurer on
that affordability before we got too far
into this whole thing let's stay on
commissioner
[Music]
adam treasurer did you want miss miller
uh good afternoon uh thanks thank you mr
chairman yes ms miller is um is um on
the call as well if if
someone could bring her
up and i think there was a question and
apologies i missed her while i was um
the question that had been raised
was about um
debt affordability at a couple different
levels i know you did send out
yes that's correct um
so um if if i recall correctly i was
asked to um
um just very you know essentially run a
few numbers um
if um
if the committee were to approve
um several um i believe it was 125
130 million
um i think the last one was 135 million
so i was um i was asked to to see if i
could run some numbers to to see what
that will do to the uh debt to revenue
ratio
and um
and what i what i was i think i
mentioned to um to the committee in the
past um
you know i think a change of 5 million
wouldn't impact the ratio so what i did
is i just
i ran all the numbers and and the only
one
um
the only number that uh really changed
the needle a bit
was the 135 million
uh figure in in our data affordability
schedule so
um so what i was trying to explain um in
the letter that i that in the memo that
i sent is um
really a change like that
even even if even if
even if um there were bonding
authorizations of 135 million
the impact on the debt to governor ratio
is very minimal
so it's just a matter of
um
really the committees the committee's
conviction as to you know how high they
would like to go
um above the 125
sort of threshold 120 i'm sorry 120
million threshold that we
included in our calculations and in our
assumptions that we provided through the
um that affordability study um report
that we distributed a couple of weeks
ago i believe
um so again so those those words just
the comments that i wanted to make and
and i and i was trying to explain that
in the memo but um
but again again i think it is it is um i
will say
that it is a committee's um decision to
to decide
um
you know at what level you want to go
you know a nexus of the 120 million that
you know we use as a threshold to
calculate um that affordability and how
much capacity the state will have to
to absorb additional debt
again as a policy decision um
i always say i feel like you know
i am responsible for running the numbers
so happy to provide all the numbers that
you want me to run
um but again and this for this
particular question that's what i could
that's what i can just um you know add
that it doesn't at least to the right uh
dead derivative ratio it doesn't have a
huge impact so the stake could perfectly
absorb that change
if the committee uh decides to to do
that
thank you
and i noticed that you did include that
if we went to that
135 if we increase our
expenditure debt service expenditure by
a little over 22 million
with the life of the bond
that's correct so um
obviously the more we bond that would be
you know the man that will um it will be
for death service so that obviously will
occur over a period of 20 years but i
just wanted to give you a figure of you
know an amount that you know that really
is what it will
it will translate to um an additional 15
50 million
will be about 22 million over the life
of the bond
thank you
representative
yes thank you and thank you for coming
um
so i i went back and i looked at the
study uh last night and i just want to
ask you a question um
so you do
include the full 50 million for the pfas
uh bonding in your estimates right
that is correct yes because i saw that
um i think it was for 2022 at least the
version i looked at or the the ratio was
6.2 and then it went up to 6.7 and the
footnotes mentioned it was because of
the 50 million um
bonding so
we have spoken to des and i know the
commissioner is here i know that they
don't anticipate at least
the last i heard that they're going to
go you know full bore with the 50
million um
but i just want to clarify that that's
that's in there in anticipation that you
you have to put in capacity
exactly and and thank you for the
question and that is um because that was
already authorized we have to either
you know to be conservative we already
put it in that fiscal year
um you know we could spread it out we
could do you know however um again
you're correct we haven't heard details
about how that you know how that project
is going we just wanted to be
conservative and include that amount and
to see what that will do to our our
metrics
and so we we wanted to see that even
when we include that 50 million our
metrics remain healthy
but again it's something that we just
have to keep in mind as more projects
are um approved and and that was an
authorization that happened
uh not during the um
approval of house bill 25 so that's you
know
we repeat the message we want to repeat
the message saying you know it's good to
maintain that capacity in case there's a
need for that additional bond and
authorization that project that you know
it really is needed and and he can't
wait so that way we're able to have you
know
the state will have that ability to
absorb that debt
and and and again looking at the numbers
in our metrics um those um appear to be
um
that we will still be in a very good
position if we maintain that um you know
that discipline as as
again as the state has done it for for
many years
can i also follow up mr chair
um
i know it's a very fuzzy situation with
the forensic hospital but have you
reflected any potential bonding for that
uh yes uh so we learned about that
possibility of having that bond and
authorization in
if no federal funds are received um
so well so so yes so including that
again unclear how much and it's going to
be authorized in house bill 25
for this time around but if we added
that amount
um
you know what i can't what i can what i
can comment on is is
for any
additional 50 million um that
is authorized
the the ratio would change um
between point two percent between two
and three point three percent between
point two and point three percent so
just to give us an idea what what that
does so if if that went to pass so we
will have to add that to our um
um
total of uh
bond then already be authorized so so
yes we have to continue so as soon as we
hear the possibility of authorizing um
um you know additional capital
appropriations that need to be bonded we
do include them in the calculation at
least we keep in mind and we start
tracking you know
how much
our numbers could change depending of
other
see none thank you very much for doing
the work and
coming back to us with
the answer question we do appreciate it
it is a pleasure thank you for having us
back
um since the question has been raised a
couple of times uh we were talking to
commissioner delay
if our commissioner scott could come up
be brought up and with whoever else he
whatever else
good afternoon mr chair and now members
of the committee uh while i was getting
uh elevated i dropped out so i i don't
know
the last 30 seconds if you said
something
uh so again i'm bob scott with the
department of environmental services and
uh thank you the questions that have
been
raised about under your department the
uh
the one-stop
um
the appropriation for the one-stop
system
and whether or not that could be
scalable or
by any or two
and
where you see it going
thank you mr chair uh short short answer
is yes
this is not an all or nothing uh i i
will say the
staff that worked this issue uh as we
developed this budget request actually
asked for even more than this to give
you an idea uh you know that but but
short answer is yes that that's
certainly something we'd be willing to
do and can do
uh you know some of the challenges as
i'm sure you're aware is
as we
have developed these these uh online
services for all our constituents uh
that's actually increased the demand for
it and as we look at
going to a more modern and certainly
more secure
uh and more accessible uh
online tools
and databases internally
we obviously have to maintain our
existing services also so it's kind of a
double whammy we have to keep what we're
doing while we're working on to to
develop that uh so it's certainly a
challenge and certainly of great
interest to us to better serve our our
constituents in to be more efficient but
short answer uh mr chairs yes
a dollar amount
by which it wouldn't be scalable anymore
no that
you could continue on with with this
project
um comfortable
i know it's going to be whatever you say
but uh if we were to take out
two million four million
five hundred thousand which kind of fall
apart
[Music]
which which one of my children do i love
best is that what you're saying um
you know again we'll work with whatever
whatever we can get but again uh
the original uh apps from staff is
actually hired to meet our needs
uh
so you know as close as we can
keep get to keeping where where our
request is obviously the happier would
be we will work with whatever the
committee uh chooses to give us
thank you uh
thank you commissioner scott
um i had uh thank you mr chairman um i
had a conversation with mr pelletier
about this he had made a phone call
and they referred me off to uh mr
taggart uh who i believe is in your
your department as opposed to uh the i.t
commissioner
and
he permitted me to see one of the
modules that you're looking to move
forward
a great presentation modeled heavily off
this the
ever successful uh subsurface
uh model uh and i expressed to pelletier
mr pelletier
uh that i think you know we're somewhat
backwards but it is somewhat opinion
that we should do in wetlands
before we do shoreland but i appreciate
the step moving forward
so my question is when you're talking
about scalability that looks like mr
taggart and others have a great amount
of work in that program your youtube
video
and it would be a great help to a major
number of people
could that program move forward with
still working on some of the others at a
uh
again uh
we'll take whatever the committee would
would uh
would give us the uh
the real issue is going to be the the
the
the one stop platform the the underlying
databases require uh mapping and work uh
so that that's one of the problems with
that uh so yes uh that's certainly a
priority for us and as you saw rep
representative mcconkey
given that that pilot if you will is
there
uh our intention would be to move that
move that forward because a lot of the
work and the mapping and all that has
been done done with that uh so
yeah the question would the next
question would if i were you i'd be
asking is when and i think we talked
about that last time uh the last capital
budget is
you know it's a matter of resources and
and uh
i don't really have a good time frame
for that as i mentioned the uh and this
is not a knock yet uh commissioner
goulet i think it's the nature of the
work
uh yeah i've i've never seen an i.t
project come in on time at least in the
state government uh and and and while i
if i could uh to your question on the
wetlands
program one of the concerns with the
wetlands program is every time the law
and or rules changes uh that would drive
it's really helpful to get all that
stabilized while we work on what the
platform would look up right so you have
the underlying law that is going to
inform
what the user and what the staff need to
do in that database and in the user
platform and it's very helpful to have
that a little bit more stabilized and
that's been a work in progress as you
know we're trying we've been trying to
uh with the wetlands rules
to uh streamline those and and uh have a
fresh set of eyes on those so i don't
thank
thank you mr chairman thank you
um i i appreciate your comments and
if you're if you're out there looking
for fresh eyes just give me a call on
wetlands thank you
yes thank you um mr chair and thank you
commissioner for coming i mean as a
member of the oil fund disbursement
board i saw firsthand how important it
is that your systems are
up and running and uh we you know it
took a while to process quite a few
requests because the system was broken
down and i fully support you keeping
everything up to snuff um there but one
thing i wanted to ask in particular is
there's a lot of interest among some of
the members and i know people in the
seacoast for the coastal flooding
finance
and
at this point
it just needs another 340 thousand
dollars to get it over the hump and i
wanted to ask you what your feeling was
as far as um how that could work out
between
your i.t budget and that appropriation
sure
again that just for the rest of the
committee uh what that work would do for
coastal uh
flooding model we have uh
the good news is we have newer data
lidar data this laser pulse data which
is much more has a higher resolution uh
and we'd be able to couple that with uh
more up-to-date uh
predictive uh
data
and we think that would be a much better
useful tool for
whether it's designing uh
new projects or just uh helping for
resiliency on the on the the coastal
flood plains so that's so that is very
important to us
uh
whether you know again ideally uh
you know to be blunt the database work
again
we have more work uh as far as what's
needed to go in and we were trying to be
believe it or not austere in what we
asked for
if you could believe that uh so in my
ideal world we'd get both
uh but uh certainly that that could come
out of that i would i would uh
remind you my understanding is
is the you know we talked last friday
about
repurposing lapse money
uh and to the extent what we asked for
would be approved which i i thought the
committee had had uh voted on that uh
that really means it's not 350 or 340 it
would be 189 would be the the delta if
you will uh
just to just to
this
um
you're right commissioner that the
approve using your lapse money for that
flood project
and i believe that
meeting last friday
we were informed that that was
usable and you could make do with that
again it's you're probably going to say
that's kind of where we were at this
morning
really
commissioner could you just speak one
more time briefly about how rapidly you
think the pfas waste management projects
will be coming along
yeah i may ask sue carlson's uh to get
elevated to see if she can weigh in also
again uh so the as you have already
discussed and the treasurer mentioned so
we had the uh
the bill passed last biennium for 50 50
million dollars of bonding
uh we had we promulgated administrative
rules on uh what we're calling the pfas
uh revolving loan fund uh and those are
in place and so that took a little bit
of time to go through that process and
my understanding is we have two
uh applications which i'm not sure even
perfected at this point so
there'll be a staging if you will as
people
decide they want to do that again these
are loans not grants so they they're
looking at
you know what opportunities are
available
uh i i will say i think the intent of
some of the sponsors certainly was uh
that applicants don't go to the drinking
water groundwater trust fund they go to
this loan fund instead but there's still
some some play in that because sometimes
there's multiple contaminants and
so
i say that in the context is certainly
we don't envision in any capacity and
we're not seeing it yet that there's
going to be boom here's 50 million that
we need to fund
uh it seems to be dribbling in if you
will and as understandably as the
the people that have the need the
municipalities uh
explore all their options obviously they
prefer to get uh a grant rather than
have to pay a loan and
when they do look at a loan obviously
they need to look at where can i get the
best rate et cetera et cetera so i don't
uh thank you for uh elevating uh our
chief operating officer susan carlson i
don't know if she had anything else to
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee
um
to your question representative ebel
we're currently looking at
between three and four million dollars
in loan requests right now
we anticipate for 22
um approximately 15 million dollars in
loans going out
and another 15 million going out and 23
and that's what we put in the operating
budget
obviously that is highly dependent on
the communities and how much
the pfas remediation will cost and how
fast they can have their bond
authorizations approved through their
towns
questions seeing that
thank you commissioner you're welcome to
stay on uh
as an attendee and figure out what we're
doing to each other
with you well
um
department of corrections i see the
commissioner is not
good afternoon members of the committee
my computer froze right mid uh
recognizing us but
i'm here for the record helen hanks
commissioner of the department of
corrections and with me is john hanson
our administrator of logistics and happy
to triage any questions the committee
may have
welcome commissioner
um there were a couple questions i'll
give you some good news first at least
100 good news
uh this morning as we were going through
um
let's propose this capital budget
we did
tentatively i say 10 weeks we haven't
taken final votes and added two projects
for you
um but
we're on your unfunded list as far as
uh doors at the at the men's prison and
for 200 000 and close customer unit for
so
that's the good news now the bad news is
people wanted to talk to you about
um
tour lines and grinders and
those types of things and how how we're
handling all of that
670 000 is sufficient too much or just
right
well uh
chair i'd like to first thank you for
the tentative good news we'll take even
tentative good news and corrections that
helps keep us motivated to the job at
hand and happy to answer
uh questions regarding the
septic and
the two different projects proposed in
this capital outlay
thank you representative
um thank you uh mr chairman commissioner
and i and i i think we may be able i
think the question was coming from me
on the grinder in the sewer line but i
think i was reminded afterwards
that this item if i could mr chairman
this line item 38 rebuild sewer line and
grinder this is the ongoing odyssey for
the project that's on the state prison
grounds
yes sir the one that's uh basically in
mcguire street yes that's correct and if
i could follow up
and the uh and i and i'm in favor of
that so we don't need to discuss in my
mind that uh my question was on another
one of your want lists which was talking
about
and off property uh of yours it was the
discussion was whether a grinder pump to
connect to the town
uh to the city sewer system or to put a
septic system
but
that so far is not funded anyway so
and i and i'm hoping you'll look at what
the alternatives really are and the cost
in the long term but i don't think we
need to take committee time to discuss
that any further mr mr chair
appreciate that and um we're recognizing
that as a
off-funded uh topic we'll send you some
information if it serves the committee
we'll send it to the whole committee of
the analysis done to date and we'll
continue to do further analysis on that
project thank you thank you commissioner
thank you mr chairman very welcome sir
any other questions representative
thank you mr chair and thank you
commissioner um i realize that this
isn't in the governor's part of the
budget but i am
curious because we've invested quite a
bit of money in the women's prison if
you could
talk to us a little bit more about the
350 000 building that you had proposed
for trades one of the reasons that uh
the women's prison had to be built was
to try to equalize programming between
the men's and the women's prison
and um
i gather that we're not all the way
there yet
and so um
there are a couple of things i just
wanted to ask you again about that
building but also to refresh our
recollection about independent
fundraising there had been done
related to those programs
thank you thank you representative abel
and your history on the department and
litigation is spot on uh yes
historically we were litigated at the
men's uh facil men's facility
specifically but
around education and vocation and now
we're currently working with new
hampshire legal assistants under
oversight regarding equity and
programming for women
so the proposed
uh building and i'll defer to john to
talk about the style of building was to
implement a trade school so we could
have equity from the perspective that we
have a diverse industries program
offered to men
automotive print shop
furniture masters and things of that
nature the current uh facility that was
designed does not have capacity through
our hvac system to put those type of
services in the existing structure so we
worked on a project with some partners
to try to find a space on the property
that would allow for
this type of trade school and education
and job skills building for women to
establish that equity the fundraising
you referenced was done and and i had a
retired member of the department who was
the liaison for that
that fundraising was specifically for
the equipment that would go into the
building so this request from the
department was to build the
infrastructure
and our collaborator was working on the
donations to outfit the interior if you
will the ff e that would go into the
building in that type of partnership so
i'd ask john just to describe this
building because we were not building it
um in a corrections grade form not
cement
because people aren't living there but
to create a space that was reasonable
within the construction realm to bring
the costs down but also achieve the goal
that's exactly right commissioner so we
were looking at a pitched roof type
building within the footprint of the
existing uh women's prison campus
would be behind the secure fencing if
you will
that that building would have a
multitude of things in there including
the wood masters group as well as some
vocational um areas to train some of the
residents on plumbing hvac and those
types of things so it's a standard
building it would look a little more
aesthetically pleasing sort of like as
you would call the c2 building with a
pitched roof and it would actually be
close to that there's a spot that we
selected for this not a huge building
but it would be an additional building
so i would just say then um
from i gather from what you're saying
that this is
part of the continuing path to com fully
complying with the court order on the
women's prison
representative
we're not in a court order
however you want to just i want to be
careful is that certainly another one of
those
no it's no problem
uh it is certainly a process we're
engaged in with new hampshire legal
assistance to review the education and
vocational program to make sure that we
have the an equitable depth of offerings
this was a logical opportunity to
diversify the job skill sets that we
would teach women who are incarcerated
and it would be establishing a level of
equity with regard to what we offer to
men so at this time i think just so the
committee knows we offer a cosmetology
program
a commissary program that is basically
modeled after manufacturing we have a um
a braille transcription program that is
not uh turned into the robust program i
had hoped it had be
would be in some other programs but we
don't have the depth of what i would
call as a as a woman the sort of
non-traditional jobs um that should be
traditional jobs that are offered to
women because of the wages associated
with them upon release to help help that
reintegration process and this seemed
like a a good investment to try to move
those initiatives forward
thank you i
one question on
any of your
projects that
you had listed as not as proposed but
not included including the government
who
did the estimating crime
on those uh like that built into this
discussion
i can answer that so um
we start out with our own internal
estimate within the department of
corrections and then public works loans
us project managers and we review them
together
in some cases uh we're high and they're
low and vice verse
but uh it is a combined effort between
the two agencies
okay even for the ones that
that like what we're discussing right
now
yes we we actually did estimating some
with a finer pencil than others but on
18 projects
thank you
go ahead
saying done
thank you very much commissioner i
appreciate your coming back and
answering questions from
members
we're happy to assist thank you for your
service to the state everyone
hello
and
what
is
um
hhs
[Music]
again some good news maybe bad news
the demolition of the wilkins building
at uh sununu center
um
when i finish talking if you can just
give us
another brief description of what that
is why it
needs to be demolished and also we're
a boiler at the barn at the community
center
but then it's all wrapped into
okay
that's all one question correct
it's all one question
i i will do my best i believe i have so
i have mr clap on the line as well who
uh
i think
dave klapp could speak to the specifics
of the buildings i know that wilkins
building has been closed for quite some
time
um it was vandalized i believe there was
also a fire there so i believe that the
building is compromised itself and we
have safety fence around it
but it still is a huge liability for
that campus for anyone trespassing on
that campus
so we i think this is not the first
capital request that we've had uh for to
demo that building
dave is did i miss anything on the
wilkins
no you are correct it was um
when
heaven found out exactly how the fire
started it was believed that it was a
homeless person in there and started the
fire and it did severely damage it was
reviewed by historical resources
and they have agreed so long as we
retain
some pieces of the building
to
yes um the
barn
boiler has failed uh we've done a
temporary work around right at this
point but it does need to be replaced
the bond is used for storage of
groundskeeping equipment some vehicles
for the
that are in use at sununu and
um some other items uh
pro
so um just a couple questions mr
so you're saying i unfortunately i can't
find the uh dhhs proposal right now but
my recollection of the boiler was that
it was to support heat not just
for a barn but for some other
external
buildings external to the center i just
don't want to put a boiler in a building
that's already collapsed you know you
know what i'm saying
yes i do know what you're saying i've
been told that it does support uh two
other buildings that are on this on the
campus right now
besides itself
i'm trying to get a hold of the
maintenance person down there to verify
which buildings they are because they
had a feeling you would be asking that
and do you think that the hundred
thousand is a solid number or do you
still have to work with public works on
that
we'll have to work with public works on
it but i think it's a pretty good number
for what we need
okay and then i had one more follow-up
um
you know we were up at glencliff and we
saw a lot of things that needed
assistance but one of your requests had
to do with the septic system up there
and
one question i had
had to do with
the cost of engineering for it even if
we can't finance the entire thing if we
were able to put together some money for
engineering a would that be helpful and
b do you have a rough idea of what that
would be
yeah the estimate that we put together
was also tied into
the addition
that was slated for up there so we have
a pretty good number on uh idea on the
number to do the repairs
uh we could do some engineering up front
that would be quite helpful i don't have
the full number on that i'd have to work
with public works to try to get a hard
represent thompson
uh commissioner or mr clap whoever wants
to take the question
on the wilkins building
has there been an environmental
assessment done on that as far as
asbestos
and
if not is that if so
is that included in the 750
thousand dollar
estimate
that is included in the 750 000
estimate to do the full demolition we do
know that there is lead paint and
there i believe there was an assessment
done on the building before and i
thank you
any other questions for
from hhs
now the the big question because we're
talking about the barn and the wilkens
and
other things
what is
how does the department view the
long-term future
of the communities that it may not be
for you that's your class but
our commissioner but it would be helpful
if you can get it
are we raising money putting any money
into any of these buildings if we're
sure thank you for the question i mean i
think it's a reasonable question to ask
are you going to be investing in a
property that we're no longer going to
be using and i can tell you this that
there will
you know it's the question that seems to
be on every committee of what is the
future of the suny news center but when
it relates to the the campus and the
needs there we currently have kids there
and we will continue to have kids there
for the foreseeable future we are in the
process of building up a system of care
which we're about a year and a half into
that we're about to launch some new
programming which that is going to have
an impact on the numbers for sunday new
but it's not going to cause the sununu
center to not have a need unfortunately
we we have a population that commits
violent crimes that that that that
require that level
of care so at this time they're in the
foreseeable future we're going to still
be on that campus now when the system of
care gets set up that's going to inform
us well what kind of facility do we need
in terms of size do we need a facility
that big i can't answer that i can't
predict the future but i can tell you
that based on some of the designs that
there will still be a need for this
level of service but how that all plays
out is is sort of
going to come together in
time
thank you
thank you mr chairman if i could return
to the conversation
on glencliff commissioner with the other
gentleman there
the
representative had asked a question
about the uh engineering for
uh what we thought was just a septic
system but it seems like you're saying
that that project also involves a
building i guess my question is
is
is this more than just a septic field is
this a is this a waste processing and
that
that building that you're talking about
uh no the
what i was
stating is we were looking at an
addition it was a project that was
submitted and not considered
and but as part of that we had built in
the um
part of the
upgrade for the septic system so the
the design
it has already been looked at we don't
have a
dollar value on the design work
but we do know that the
the value of the septic system
uh is
is that 1.2 million i believe it is
um
for the the system and it is only for
the system it's not for the building
thank you sir
yes at this um
representative abel
um
well i guess i would ask the i.t
question again there's um i mean i think
we have a sense that we're not gonna
do too much with the hhsit request
because so much of it is federally
funded but
again um just you know a hundred
thousand dollars can buy a boiler versus
10 or 20 million so
i didn't know if there was any
comment anybody could make on
scalability for any of the programs or
how they would be affected
thank you thank you for the question i
don't know if dennis is still on the
line however i think i think
commissioner goulet summed it up pretty
well in terms of that there was a dry
spell for hhs for quite some time and
we're behind and as you know a lot of
compliance and facing fines
you know that said i mean is there room
to look at something to see where we can
do that i think the complexity for a lot
of our projects is once you tap into
that you have to tap in to get enough of
a general fund return given the high
percentage of the 90
federal match
so if that was a request that's
something that we could look into but i
i think when dennis looks and talks
about
uh the the impact of it in terms of the
serving the citizens and he had two
metrics that he used those are things
that we await with him in terms of
making these projects a priority and of
course the capital budget is very
challenging because everybody's project
is a priority right and your committee's
job is very
next to impossible to do i completely
understand that but if we if he wanted
us to ask us to do that we could i just
don't know what the outcome would be if
we would actually be able to do that i
don't have dave leaders on the phone um
to answer that but
any other questions for
see you none commissioner thank you very
much for taking the time to be with us
this
that
um
we've gone through everything
before we go back through a couple of
the things
there are two things that we need to
address
and
we retained two separate house bills
in order to see
if the monies could be incorporated into
the capital budget
making an appropriation
uh for the digitization
of the supreme court records
there is a capital appropriation that
would be associated with it i would
remind everybody
that
neither the judicial branch nor das who
were involved in this
um wanted to take on the project as
as shepherding the project
in my contact with the archive the state
archives
they wanted a lot more information and
data
before they would agree to take it on as
well and they're not sure about the cost
but
we did retain it to say that we would
look at it in conjunction with the
capital budget
we don't have to do anything
and make a recommendation to the house
as a whole
but from
past experience
if we don't include into the capital
budget most
members of the committee don't want to
entertain capital projects outside the
capital budget except for very rare
instances
so when is the pleasure of the committee
this
representative
i believe i made the
original motion to retain it for this
purpose
and as such and having worked through
this capital budget and seeing how tight
our pennies are
uh at this point in time i would be
willing to just let it stay retained and
we can look at it
next time
next year and
there's always the same side there's
still the center side so i i would just
say at this point in time we don't look
to put any money towards it
other
mr chairman
i don't have the bill in front of me how
much money are you talking about
um
it was nine years
um i've got it here
uh fy 22 250 000 fy23
500 so 750 for this biennium and then
one point
two plus
so it's a multivitamin it's a
multi-biennium
and 750 up front
okay
all right okay
um yeah i i i don't know i
tend to think it maybe just to keep it
retained for now unless the senate puts
it in there version i
suppose
hopefully we will go to the communities
of conference this year
um when we get to those things but our
goal right now is to come up with a hb
25 that we can get passed to the second
the second bill
that um
we retained
um i was prime sponsor
um
that does not make it right um it is an
act making
the federal stafford county straight
rail
improvements project and making an
appropriation for the crews county
freight rail improvement project
both of those
rail lines that the
original bill requested 2 million
each
to be matched
by an equal amount from those two
railroads
we retained it to see if there could be
any monies
appropriated for
a match to those railroads
speaking as the prime sponsor and not as
chair
the past we have provided some funds
never what they asked for
and they have made their
matches on time
and they have reported to the capitol
budget overview committee when they were
supposed
however
as we've been talking all day
this is a tight budget
um so
what is the
committee's
desire
representative mccarthy
uh thank you mr chairman
um and in an effort to uh pull one of
the chairman's bills forward i'd like to
offer
um
and i i agree with what the chairman had
just spoken about that we have provided
some funding for both of these railroads
over the past and they've been very
upfront with the money spent and they've
done their projects so i know these
numbers are nowhere near what we're
asked for originally
and
i
still haven't narrowed down which of the
two railroads it is but i believe in
okay which was the
250 000 proposal
uh so uh the project the chairman had
just mentioned
uh i would look to add 250 000
to the capital budget
and the second would be the
cost
the coast county
increased by 500 000. it's not a lot of
money but i
i think it stands
uh with what this uh committee has done
in the past and shows a willingness to
keep our rail projects especially
freight moving forward i will second
that motion
consecutive that
um
that will incorporate some
of
the language from house
120 122
um
for
line in the south and
500 000
to the coast county freight lines for a
total of
750 000 between the two of them there
which responds generally with the caveat
that
ah thank you i have located where this
is in the 2019
hospital 25 they are blind items
in department of transportation general
which is roman 16 xbi
so there are two letters one item for
koss and elena for strafford and carol
uh they have a footnote
that says that the sums appropriated
shall be a match to private funds and
that they have to report the capital
budget overview so
i would guess the motion should be that
appropriations or funding and move
forward it is not
um i know the one that goes
they got the full two million dollars
they could complete the project
but to come up with another 1.5
capital budget is
near impossible
um
as we look at all of
the things that state owns that need to
continue forward
but as i said when i introduced these
bills both of these railroads keep
hundreds if not thousands of large
trucks off of our work
year round so that's
it is a wonderful goal representative
evil
yes thank you mr chair i just wanted to
clarify
this amount that you're proposing now
is the amount that we
did a straw poll on from your sheet
earlier today it's the same amount
um
okay but it's it's what's on here all
right thank you
right we stopped for lunch at that point
oh
i ate too much tuna
i i just wanted to reiterate for this
brother you were members of the
committee and you just you just said it
uh part of the reason that we do this in
this committee is because these trains
do help keep all that truck traffic off
the road and we're having you know we
have enough time truck tough time with
our
pavement resurfacing yes it is anyway so
this has always been money well spent
inspect here
any other questions or comments about
yes thank you um
i gotta say i kind of fundamentally
disagree with this
idea of subsidizing a private company
and
two things when
with this testimony i remember asking uh
about how they verified the match on
that
and the fellow said that they pay for
this all up front and they get then get
the money from the state
which makes you wonder
why do they need our money you know they
have enough to pay for that
and the other thing
i'm involved with trucking and when you
say 37 or it was said 37 000 trucks uh
trips per year with trucks
well if you went down to the hampton
tolls
and sat down here
i bet that's about maybe a day's worth
of trucks if that there so it sounds
like a very large number but i think i
don't know if it's as impressive as i
would think but at any rate i'm a new
guy here
it's just my impression and um i will
any other comments
yeah i just
with all due respect i think this is an
issue
not so much in this budget but constant
complaints about heavy trucks damaging
our roads like whatever we could do
within reasons as long as the companies
want to match or exceed it to get put
more of the freight in rail which is a
lot better way to
do it this is a public what we call a
public private partnership we do these
all the time
i'm not in paper
um
and i the reason i'm not and i don't
know how many of you have read it but
the last
i think in 2010
and at that point in time it indicated
that less than one percent of the
freight carried through
and into the state of new hampshire
um goes by rail
and when that report was written they
were basing that on
a
large quantity of that uh traffic came
from the paper mills in the berlin area
which no longer exists maryland groved
um
and 70 of the rail traffic in and out of
the state is the 100 train
coal cars that go to the vol power plant
on a weekly basis
that amounts to 70
of the 1 handled by ram
so
i agree with
we're subsidizing a private company
and
my experience in the north country and i
don't know about the rest of the state
but in the north country the saint
lawrence railway
takes railcars through there about twice
a week
and they come from maine
they go to vermont and into canada
and they never drop any freight in the
state of new hampshire or to the best of
my knowledge pick any trade up in the
state of new hampshire it's a
pass-through rail system
so i'll be voting against it as well
okay
yeah just one final one uh
because both the gentlemen are nuanced
to me it's been a number of years since
this actually came up uh this has come
up before and in the past we've had the
and we don't have the luxury of having
them with us today we did not anticipate
this question would come up but these
two rail lines the money that we put
towards them are
specifically geared to transportation
into new hampshire this isn't passed
through this one one was a route
actually up into
uh
representative mcconkie's area i think
it was hauling gravel or something up
there so
this this money has always been for
interest interstate not interested
okay sorry i couldn't unmute it but i
just figured out how it switched to my
representative philadelphia
yes
representative newton
representative
no
go back representative yeah i said yes
i'm sorry
sorry thank you i didn't hear that
representative
representative thompson
uh no
representative clunier yes
representative edgar all right
representative ebel
yes
representative jack yeah
representative faulkner
yes
representative grassy
representative peterson
yes
representative quarry
representative bunker
yes
sharon graham yes
mr chair the vote passes 17-2
i'm sorry the motion passes all right
that will be included
um
i'd like to take about 15 or 20 minutes
to go back through some of what we did
this morning
having heard
and the reason i'm doing this
is
we do need to get
started
on a fairly lengthy amendment
to hospital 25.
and
a meeting like this makes it a little
more difficult to get with the lba and
the rest
um
administrative services
i put an asterisk against line 14
first mitigation information cloud
environment for 5.1 million dollars
there any objection to leaving that in
as
written
team nine
um we approved reducing
um statewide emergency fund to one
um
department of
corrections we had put an asterisk next
to
grinder but that was answered
is there any other questions about
corrections
there is some disagreement under the
department of education about the
bathroom
uh at the d.o.e
um but the vote of the committee was to
go ahead and add it
as we go forward at least on this
comparison
i assume that the ejections are still
there
am i trying to change anybody's thoughts
environmental services
we put an asterisk next to one stop it
system upgrades
uh at a little over five million
any comments on that
um mr shea
i didn't have a comment to that
specifically represent graham but i was
wondering if as you go through
if you added a project
in house bill 25 but also added a piece
of it into the
uh repurposing amount if you could just
i can go over i can send you a complete
list
that would be great
then that's fine that way chris
and trying to do it here let that in
front of me and representative mills but
well if you can send me something after
today that that would or after the
meeting that would be great and i can
um representative jack thank you i'd
love to uh if we need a motion i'd like
to empower the chairman and mr shay
to go back over the decisions we made
about where the last money is going
so that they can do it the simplest way
rather than do it the way we voted on
them
it's gonna it's gonna happen anyway
without objection we'll take that and mr
shea and i will work on it and provide
it to the committee on where the money
is coming from
i don't want to try to do this in a
vacuum even though it seems like i've
been loving this railroad all day
um
from zambibo
um so we're back on the des uh budget
um
so i i looked this up when to in order
to get the 350 000 for the coastal
flooding we need 188 i'm sorry if i had
the number wrong before
there's two ways i guess that we could
do that i mean this is something that i
would like to discuss with the committee
there's two ways we could do it one is
to simply reduce the one one-stop i.t
budget by 108 and put it toward
the coastal the other option is that in
the past we've given committees some i
mean
department some latitude to move money
back and forth and so one other thing we
could do without hitting the bottom line
is just to give des the option
to use some of the i.t money for the
coastal flooding if that was something
that they
felt that they
could do and
again this wouldn't hit our bottom line
it would accomplish uh things that or
help to accomplish some of the things
that our
coastal folks uh are interested in doing
that clearly is another economic engine
for the um
for the state and i also took what
representative thompson had said to hart
about all the work that's been done down
there so
i don't know what the committee's
pleasure is but um i would propose doing
thank you mr chairman and if i could
address representative eagle
um
but my first question is for you mr
chairman had hadn't we penciled in this
morning a number of somewhere around 160
yes
it's
[Music]
i if i could mr chairman continue
i i'm in i am um having not spoken much
in favor of this i'm more than willing
to go forward with the
164 thousand dollar figure
um what wherever that number was we
penciled in this morning
um the commissioner talked about
that they'll spend what they can and
that is so close to that number
um my second my second is on the uh
the five million dollars for the one
stop
i've had time to reflect on that
i'm not so much in taking away the money
from that because i believe it's a
needed program
what i ask the chairman to do
is i'm wondering if we could footnote
that
or make that appropriation a lot of
times they have to spend a lot of that
money up front is my understanding i'm
not as well versed as representative
jack about that but i would like to see
them report to a
capital budget overview when they hit
the three million dollar figure
on progress made with that and the
modules
and then
that they will report to us going
forward
every time they spend a million dollars
and i don't see that we're going to be
in their way but i think when we're
spending five million dollars i think
the proper vehicle is oversight with
capital budget overview so i would be in
favor of keeping that that appropriation
and i would uh
not be in favor of going from the 160
something to 180
my feeling is uh
in and i use the one step system on a
um
as far as subsurface goes i think it's
working well now
better than it ever has um
promises have been made over the years
to us
as installers and designers that
there were going to be functions that
system
that's never repaired
um
and
i think five million dollars is a lot of
money to give them
to
uh without some specific goals in mind
and i didn't hear
any specifics from the commissioner
again i didn't ask him for any
but uh i didn't hear any specifics on
how exactly this is going to approve the
overall so
that seems like a lot of money to commit
to something i would
support uh representative mcconkie's
idea of having some oversight is this
money spent
and i think that
and
in all honesty
um having said on this committee and on
capitol hill
i think we need probably to
strengthen the language for all of the
agencies to come back in and tell us how
they're spending
the millions particularly
giving to them
um not a periodic
someone that should be quarterly and
some of it should be semi-annually
um
but at least get
a report of where the money is so that
all of a sudden you don't have five
billion dollars being lapsed at the next
fight
by
evil suggested of raising
dollar amount for
and
encountered by representative conkey are
there any other comments
and i know where representative edgar is
uh thank you mr chairman thanks john um
i uh
obviously i'm in favor of any emotions
to uh to increase the uh coastal
flooding monitoring
um
issue right here and uh
believe me i'm i'm i'm really glad that
uh is a minimum i hope when we get done
that we can get in that range the
hundred and you know sixty one eighty
eight ninety um
i think
there's a there's an awful lot of
support for this uh uh on the seacoast
and and up the pasquatica
and uh
if if we can take it out you know
whack a little bit off of one stop that
would be good or if there's some other
way of doing it
and i appreciate any consideration on it
um
but you know i realize that this you
know this really is a tight budget right
now but i i hope we could find that much
any other
comments on this
can i just ask sure are we are we trying
to add another 889 to this 161. yes
that's right
yes that's the suggestion 340
yeah
110.
that's not the word precise right no
well we've got 161 90 in there from the
last line so that's the exact figure
i have some idea of how this process
works out
and i can tell you that with 161
thousand dollars they're not going to be
able to accomplish
what they need to accomplish
i'd like to see it fully funded at their
request
but we have a motion on the floor i'd
like to you know i don't know represent
evil
she did not make a motion she just kind
of threw the idea out there okay
um
i mean so we put allocated this is from
last money this morning 100 about 161
correct and i believe as i understood
representative evil she wanted to add to
the same program of coastal flooding
another 180
to be taken if i understood her
correctly directly to be taken from the
des
one stop
if i could uh that that was an option
that i put out there um i i mean we
could try a motion i'd make that um the
other alternative i had mentioned is
simply writing into the
bill that we give
des the ability to switch money from
between i i.t and the coastal flooding
for that 188
if they wanted to
but
if
i'm willing to make a motion if the
chair thinks that
this is the time
it's the time the center
okay um
i
move that
i may not have all the details here i
move that the uh des one stop
it budget
sorry if somebody can help me here i'm
trying to find the amount is it five
thirteen thousand five hundred dollars
we're getting reduced
by 1088
i'm sorry 188
for that money to be
allocated to the
what are we putting in
the postal flooding program
yes thank you very much mr clerk for
helping me that is that's my motion
basically that the one-stop budget item
be reduced by 188
whatever mr mills said thousand um to be
used for the coastal flooding program
but
any discussion on that to reduce that
one stop fractionally
by approximately 188 000
and
uh
to
be used for
yes i would just say that the
commissioner said himself
that if we ended up cutting money out of
the one-stop budget he'd make it work
that's why i think anybody's really
you never said in front of a committee
until you can use less
i just want to just i just wanted to be
clear in my own head so
uh this morning we talked about uh
taking laps money of 161
something a thousand and now we're
talking about then finding another 188
million
188 000 excuse me
of money that they uh hadn't been
brought forward so we're somewhere
around uh
320 thousand hours
188 and change of new funding yeah
of new funding we are reauthorizing that
so what i'm just saying is a project
that was on the walk list
that wasn't brought forward we're now
going to appropriate uh
330 000
too so it's not that we're just putting
000 away from one we're putting
we're spending over 300 000
combined 350 000 so that will be the
that will be the reason i am
i'm supportive of the money this morning
any other
questions
please
representative mcconkey
everybody clear on what we're working on
i see
no buddy shaking their head okay
representative mcconkey nay
chair boats no
no
representative newton
no representative blasic
representative boards
representative kozinski
no
representative kolansky
representative thompson yes
representative clutier yes
representative edgar
yay
representative ebal
yes
representative jack yes
representative faulkner
yes
representative newman
representative bassey yes
representative peter peterson
yes
representative query
representative bunker
yes
the motion passes
11 to 6.
i'm sure that we will talk about this
again
um but for now
that motion passes and will be included
in the
we shall go
on um
same with judicial branch anything about
those two
um
commission is there
bonds other
service credit card
we made a change in the military affairs
and veteran services
by utilizing
some last money and 415 000 to leverage
i have six hundred thousand dollars
of uh additional federal money
uh for statewide federations of
readiness
systems and all of the rest
on here is federal money
natural cultural resources
um
we increase roofing and repair
to
1.35 million from the 1.2 that the
governor had proposed
any questions on that
these standards and training
remain the same as did the veterans home
safety of the
department of safety
there were
we
left the 750 000 the governor talked
about
and we also then repurposed the lapse
that we
approved
which was fire academy
our department of transportation
under general funds
we
um
approved their 1.72
022 dollars
and we added the two railroads when it's
250 000.
the other at
500 000.
um we will look and see what that does
to our bottom line
and then in section two which is highway
funded
d.o.t
we approved the amendment that was
drafted under my name
for changing how they spent some of that
money and it increased it about a
million dollars
you all should have that
um
that was it
university system
um it did not change and when did i miss
the community college system
we left what the governor proposed
and added one million dollars for
that's all of the agencies
i will work with mr shade
to come up with a new
uh spreadsheet
if you have art and get that out people
um i do not have right now i have asked
for
two days next week
with a zoom license
one is start with the work session make
sure we're all in agreement
and then
have an executive session on an
amendment which
takes into consideration everything that
we have
discussed and changed and changed at the
next work session if we change anything
i would like to come out of this with a
consensus
on the bottom line when we finish we may
not all agree on any given project
but
we are trying to do the best for the
state
i will try also to get some more
definitions
before our next session
on
what strings or how
the money that is coming
under
going to be handled
i think that that is
an important thing to know
you know
there's going to be one or two large
fighters a whole bunch of small it's all
those things that are unknown at this
point so i think that we need as a
committee
and as a general court need to weigh in
on what is going on
do i have anything else from anybody
who's here representative jack i thank
you
if we're going to have a section on it's
defense of the committee that we see the
federal funds on
i'd like to consider adding the
women's prison trades building as one of
and
i would certainly support that
now why don't we do it this way because
we're going to have another work session
before the finalization of remember
everybody spend the next few days
thinking about
going back through
the agency presentations
um and what we've heard what we know
and say if federal money becomes
available
this is the project i would like to see
done
and don't
you know because i i look at things like
this uh
the leaky roof at the berlin men's
prison
uh that would probably be a nice thing
to fix since
plus
little things like that
i am sure that several people will
talk about more money for
the
community college system or other
or other agencies
and
we shall see but
look through their presentations
look through
this book
um
because there's lots of
unfunded things that were priorities for
that
and if nothing else we can at least make
our desires known to the senate
and to
the governor whoever will
be receiving this money
um so if you could do that i think that
trying to do it right now is going it's
quarter or three in the afternoon
we've been here since 9 15 9 30.
um
we're just not
i'm not as quite as i was
10 years ago but
you saved but definitely not 10 hours
ago
so
so we're going to come in tuesday for a
work session you could come in probably
thursday right yeah if i can work that
and if i if we can get the work session
done early enough on tuesday
so they can start working on
the amendment some of the amendments
that they may be able to start with
um you know which lapses are being
dropped in those kinds of things
but uh it's going to depend on
on us working
tuesday morning get it done
um
and then let the amendments get drafted
because that is what we actually do
is everybody right
it's like any other bill it's up or down
from the committee and goes to the floor
okay and we're starting at 9 30 on soon
it's like on tuesday
hopefully i don't have to get it
scheduled with this week's calendar so
licenses
when the calendar had to go to bed
so i will be working on that
and it is your intent i mean hopefully
we can do it tuesday tuesday thursday
and not have to come back unless you
said something if necessary the
following monday yeah
okay and that puts it really tight
because that is the deadline week and
there are
i think uh
400 some odd bills
that still have to
make it through
committees and
either be retained or go on to the
calendar
so your intent is trying to wrap things
up by thursday yeah my intent is next
week okay yeah all right just so
it is a little harder with with
i mean
members of the lba not being in the
building not being in the room with us
they are doing a phenomenal job
i'm doing it this way
it is helpful and and
but that's why i'd like to get it done
as early tuesday as possible we give him
as much time
and he and i will be in contact over the
next couple of days
trying to iron out everything that we
decided so it makes sense to him and the
drafters
it's very important that the drafters
know what they're doing
okay and one other thing for the sake of
because hopefully we get a draft
amendment done by late tuesday so that
we can look it over
um because i think you know from the
past you and i have sometimes we've had
some mistakes that we've had to come in
for a special meeting just to
correct and that's why i said it's
required for the following monday okay
but if we meet tuesday
um agree on everything i don't think
that they'll have uh
um
i think so
unless i get told otherwise
um
now let me tell you what the speaker
said to the chairs and vice chairs
on monday morning
it's in the
um calendar
we will be meeting the 7th 8th and 9th
of april at the bedford sports complex
his intention is to start at 9 00 each
morning
and we go till six or seven in the
uh as i said we've got hundreds of bills
that we've got to get through
so if you have any friends who want to
debate
us bill 25
please ask them not to
or make it one-on-one be against
somebody um
well it's it's just with 400 yeah even
if you only take three minutes each uh
each side and start running into time
and there are
um
obviously some issues that are more
passionate than the capital budget that
people wanted to talk about
um
but
we have to get our work done those three
days
and i know that the majority of minority
leaders agreed to suspend uh
changing the the deadlines and changing
crossover date
but that's about as far as we can go
because the senate still has to get the
bills
i'll schedule those at some point
probably after the night i mean
thank you mr chairman uh for new members
and i
i'm appalled that we haven't had the
time to spend each other to look each
other in the eye but the the history of
this committee has been if we're going
to thrash this out i think we're very
close to being done so i don't mean
thrash was way off base we need we need
to
come together on tuesday figure this out
and as the chairman alluded we'll come
out with a opinion
we never
we it's you can do it but we we would
prefer not
again with the history of our committee
not to have a member speak against
another member of this committee on the
floor
we're one of the few committees that is
united
and
and we will come together on tuesday and
i'm hoping we can take care of it then
thank you
and finally i heard mr chairman that
that the intent of the speaker is to
take up the the budget bills which i
assume would be house built on the first
day we meet them wednesday
because i think it's wednesday thursday
and friday
that's what i
thursday friday what he told the chairs
on monday morning was there will
probably be three parts of the calendar
with the must-pass bills on
uh wednesday
and i i make the assumption that that's
one two and 25 because they're money
bills
and there's probably a couple others in
other committees that people think of
are are critical
but i would not be surprised if we
weren't the third or fourth motion i i
think we should be first frankly i would
suggest that's what i did when i was i
asked her to go first because of the
option he did it
if i get away with it if you get it up
uh
of representative jack on the capital
142 and 143.
i don't claim to understand
this or the wording of it i wondered if
it's uh two items on the river turning
basin
continued
uh there's not there's money in those
but what this does is it was brought our
proof in fire by instance
when the
the
congressional delegation finally got um
the court of engineers off the dime
the costume is higher and that's why uh
miss marconi had to come in for an
additional 1.7 so they're
52 left was given before okay i didn't
get that from the conversation well
sometimes uh mr cody
gets excited
any other comments or questions before i